GOOD MORNING WE WANT TO CALL TO
ORDER SAID FIVE OF THE BUDGET.
.
WANT TO WELCOME YOU I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER WHO IS THE
CHAIR OF SEPT FIVE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA
CALL ROLE WE HAVE MISTER.
OBERNOLTE SITTING IN A DAY FOR
MISS MELENDEZ.
STONE HERE WEBER HERE OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU.
THAT ESTABLISHES A QUORUM FOR
US THEN BEGIN.
.
THE ITEMS THAT ARE LISTED OF
BEGINNING WITH THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER OF CALIFORNIA.
THE SUSTAINABLE REHABILITATION
YOU ACT
I KNOW THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
.
VERY BUSY I SHOULD SAY MORNING
FOR MANY OF US SO IF YOU HAPPEN
TO SEE SOME OF US GO INTO NOW.
IT'S NOT IN PROTEST OF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING BECAUSE WE BECAUSE
WE HAVE A HEARING OR
PRESENTATION IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE I EVEN HAVE A MEETING
MYSELF THAT HAS BEEN SCHEDULED.
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS HEARING.
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO I WILL HAVE TO. ALSO GO TO
THAT MEETING FOR A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME. A BUT WE WANT TO BEGIN
THIS MORNING WITH THE CHIEF
PROBATION OFFICER I'D ISSUE
NUMBER ONE.
SO WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
BUT TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
THE OWNER OF THE PROPOSAL.
SHOULD. THOSE THOSE HERE SHOULD
HAVE PLAYED.
FLYER INFORMATION CONCERNING
THAT.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS TODAY
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK ALL OF OUR.
PRESENT PRISONERS TO GRIEF IN
THEIR PRESENTATIONS.
MANY OF US HAVE SEEN THE
MATERIAL I READ THE ITEMS
MATERIAL FOR MOST OF THE ITEMS
WILL BE HELD OPEN. ALSO THAT
WON'T BE VOTING ON THE ITEMS
TODAY.
WE WILL BE VOTING NEXT WEEK SO
WHEN I ASK YOU TO TRY TO BE AS
BRIEF AS POSSIBLE. THOSE WHO'VE
COME TO DO.
STATEMENTS ON BEHALF ALSO
TREATMENT WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES.
TO INDIVIDUALS IF YOU HAVE TO
UP TO TO TO HAVE A SUPPORTING
STATEMENTS ARE AND THOSE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO WANT TO MAKE
COMMENTS WERE SIMPLY GOING TO
ASK THAT YOU COME FORWARD. GIVE
US THE NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION
WHERE THE IN FAVOR ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE PROPOSAL.
SO WILL BEGIN AND PLEASE THOSE
WHO A TO L. HERE TODAY TABLE BE
SURE TO GIVE US YOUR NAME.
CERTAINLY GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ
WITH THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA AYE WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
TIME.
ON THE AGENDA TO TALK ABOUT OUR
PROPOSAL THIS MORNING.
THAT YOU PROVISIONAL THERE'S A
CALIFORNIA HAVE DONE ON
SIGNIFICANT WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE LAST
DECADE.
TO MAKE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE ARENA.
WE HAVE LOWER DETENTION RATES
BY SIXTY PERCENT A JUVENILE
ARREST RATES BY SEVENTY THREE
PERCENT. I'M ACTUALLY THE
MAJORITY OF THE YOUTH THAT WE
SERVE I'M A NINETY PERCENT OF
THE YOUTH THAT ARE IN THAT
COUNTY SYSTEM ARE ACTUALLY
SUPERVISED IN THE COMMUNITY SO
WE HAVE DONE. ON A GREAT DEAL OF
WORK.
REALLY ON THE FRONT END IN
TERMS OF DIVERSION.
AND PREVENTION WITH JUVENILE
SERVICES.
BUT KIND OF WHERE WE'RE AT
TODAY AS AS A RESULT OF THAT.
CAN A DECADE OF PROGRESS IS
THAT.
THERE IN THE DAY YOU THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN OUR JUVENILE HALLS
IN CAMPS ARE REPRESENT AND YOU
KNOW YOU THOUGHT HAVE.
SIGNIFICANT NEEDS AND SOMETIMES
VERY CUTE NEEDS A BIT OF COURSE
ARE FACILITIES THAT WE HAVE MANY
OF WHICH WHERE. I'M FROM DECADES
AGO AND THEY REPRESENT KIND OF A
DIFFERENCE.
OUTLOOK ON.
JUVENILE JUSTICE SERVICES ON
WHAT WE ARE.
REQUESTING.
VIA THIS COMMITTEE TODAY IS A
THIRTY MILLION AND ONE TIME
STATE GRANTS THAT WOULD GO
TOWARDS THE REPURPOSE SCENE OF.
JUVENILE HALL.
THE JUVENILE CAMP OR SOME
PORTION THEIR OF.
FOR THE PURPOSES OF.
PROGRAMMING FOR THE PURPOSES OF
CREATING MORE THERAPEUTIC HOME
LIKE SETTINGS. ON SO THAT WE CAN
REALLY MATCH UP ALL THE THINGS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT ON
PROGRAMMING AND SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH SUBSTANCE USE. MAKING
SURE THAT THOSE SERVICES ARE
OFFERED IN A SETTING THAT IS
MOST CONDUCIVE TO TO THE JUST.
THESE YOUTH BEING ABLE TO.
REALLY BENEFIT FROM THOSE
SERVICES.
.
THIS AYE I DO WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS WOULD PRESENT NO NEW
BEDS ON TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT WE
ACTUALLY SEE THIS AS A NET
REDUCTION POTENTIALLY WHERE.
CERTAIN BED SPACE MIGHT
ACTUALLY BE REMOVED FOR
PROGRAMMING PURPOSES ON OR AGAIN
REPURPOSE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SETTINGS THAT ARE MAYBE SMALLER
GROUPS AND MORE HOME LIKE.
AND SO WE WE SEE THAT REDUCTION
AS WE MOVE TOWARDS KIND OF A
DIFFERENT.
DIFFERENT MODEL IN SERVING THE
YOUTH IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ON THE YOUNG ADULT POPULATION
KIND OF THAT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE. ON ARE THE HIGHEST ON IS
THE POPULATION THAT IS ON MOST
NOTABLY GOING INTO STATE PRISON
AND SO. ON BIKE AND CONTINUING
TO MAKE PROGRESS IN THE JUVENILE
ARENA WE FEEL LIKE WITHOUT ALSO
HELPS CAN TO STEM THE TIDE. I'M
AS TO WHO GOES INTO STATE PRISON
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY HAS A RETURN
ON INVESTMENT BOTH FROM THAT.
THE ABILITY OF THAT YOU TOOK TO
TURN THEIR LIFE AROUND ON AND
THEN FROM THAT THE TYPE OF KIND
OF FACTORS THAT THIS COMMITTEE
LOOKS THAT.
SO I WANT TO I STOP THERE AND
INTRODUCE AYE CHIEF TERRY
MCDONALD CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AMONG WITH
MANY OTHERS HAS DONE SOME
WONDERFUL THINGS ON IN THIS AREA
ON REPURPOSE SEEN FACILITIES SO
I'D LIKE TO TURN IT OVER HER TO
TALK LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
MADAM CHAIR TERRY MCDONNELL
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICER MEMBERS
GOOD TO SEE SOME OF YOU HAVE MET
BEFORE I HAVE THE.
THAT DISTINCT HONOR OF SERVING
BOTH CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS I LEFT THERE IS THE
UNDERSECRETARY OF OPERATIONS
OVER PRISON PAROLE JUVENILE
JUSTICE REFILL TAPE SERVICES I
THEN WENT ON TO OVERSEE THE
REFORMS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
JAILS. WORKING FOR THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND NOW THE HONOR OF
THE PROBATION SHE.
A WHAT I KNOW IS IS THAT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WAS A
BAD TOOL. FOR.
HEALTH ISSUES
AND SO THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM EXPLODED.
AND IT TIME IT EXPLODED IN THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM IS A BEGAN TO
BUILD DETENTION CENTERS IN EVERY
COUNTY. THAT WERE INFORMED BY
WHAT WAS CALLED SUPER PREDATOR
USE.
AND SO WHAT YOU HAVE LEFT IN LA
COUNTY HOSPITAL A COUNTY
SPECIFIC WHERE FACILITIES THAT
ARE NOT WELL DESIGNED. FOR THE
TRAUMA INFORMED CARE THAT OUR
CLIENTS NEED.
OUR CLIENTS NEED THE ABILITY TO
GOING TO GROUP AREAS TO
CLASSROOMS TO LIVE IN
ENVIRONMENTS THAT AREN'T LARGE
DORM ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THEY
DON'T FEEL SAFE.
TO PROVIDE AN AREA IN WHICH
CBO'S CAN COME INTO WORK WITH US
TO PROVIDE TROHMAN INFORMED CARE
WE CAN WORK WITH FAMILIES TO DO
RESTITUTION WE CAN WORK WITH
VICTIMS. TO HEAL RELATIONSHIPS
BETWEEN VICTIMS IN YOUTH BUT
THAT COSTS MONEY.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
WITH CLOSE NINE CAMPS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ONE OF THE CAMPS
THE BOARD AUTHORIZED YESTERDAY
FOR US TO TURN IT INTO
RESIDENTIAL VOCATIONAL TRAINING
CENTER. FOR EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD YOUNG MAN THAT'S A
MILLION DOLLARS TO DO THAT
RENOVATION FOR THE COUNTY. NOW
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
FOUNDATION TO PAY FOR THAT BUT
IMAGINE. IF COUNTIES HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMPETE FOR FUNDS
TO RENOVATE FACILITIES TO ADDED
MORE TREATMENT FACILITIES TO
REPURPOSE AYE AREAS FOR COLLEGES
FOR. OF TRAITS FOR VOCATIONS AND
REALLY BEGAN TO FOCUS ON THE
PROFOUND NEEDS
THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE. IT'S
AFFRONT AND INVESTMENT THAT
ACTUALLY REDUCES THE FORWARD
INTO OUR JAILS AND PRISONS AND
AND I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT PROBABLY HAS A
BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE. FROM ONE TO THE NEXT TO
THE NEXT.
I KNOW THAT IF WE CAN JUST HELP
THE COUNTIES PUT IN THE KIND OF
SERVICES THAT YOUNG PEOPLE NEED
TO RESPOND TO IT IN A PLACE IN
WHICH THEY FEEL SAFE.
AND THEY FEEL VALUED AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE TRAUMA IN WHICH
WE GO TO IF WE CONTINUE TO RUN
FACILITIES THAT LOOK LIKE LEVEL
FOR PRISONS.
OR BIG DORMS THAT LOOK LIKE.
SOME KIND OF A HOMELESS
ENVIRONMENT FOR USE THAN WE'RE
GOING TO GET THE OUTCOMES THAT
NONE OF A SEAT. SO WE URGE A
SUPPORT TO THINK ABOUT
DISABILITY FOR COUNTIES TO
COMPETE FOR THIS I ALSO WELCOME
YOU TO COME OUT TO CAMPUS
KILPATRICK THE STATE INVESTED.
OVER FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN SB
EIGHTY ONE AND THE CAMPUS
KIRKPATRICK AND THERE'S A LITTLE
PICTURE OF IT RIGHT HERE. THIS
FACILITY DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A
JUVENILE DETENTION FACILITY IT
ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE A CAMPUS
THE LIVING ENVIRONMENTS HOME
LIKE FOR THE YOUTH THERE'S
PLENTY OF PLACES IN WHICH WE CAN
ENGAGE IN VOCATIONAL TRAINING
THERE'S A. THERE'S A CULINARY
ARTS SCHOOL THERE. THIS IS THE
DIRECTION IN WHICH THIS GREAT
STATE NEEDS TO GO IN AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT IN HELPING HELPING
A PROBATION DEPARTMENTS DO THAT.
THANK YOU.
TAKING MY NAME IS FRENCH LZ BELL
AND.
I'M RECENTLY RELEASED FROM
PRISON AFTER DOING THIRTY FIVE
YEARS
SEVENTEEN ADULTS.
YEARS WAS ATROCIOUS.
PERIOD I DIDN'T GET IT. I HAD NO
EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE.
AS ARE YOU ARE BEEN TO ALMOST
ALL OF HER FACILITIES.
ALL THEY DID WAS PUT ME THERE TO
KEEP ME SAFE AND AWAY FROM
SOCIETY FOR THE CRIMES THAT ARE
COMMITTED.
IT WAS ONLY UNTIL LAST SEVENTEEN
YEARS OF MY LIFE AT EVAN LOW
STATE PRISON THAT I ACTUALLY
LEARN. THE ORIGINS OF MY
BEHAVIOR MY MISS PA EVERY PUT IT
LIKE THAT. IF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
HAVE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT IN ORDER
TO LEARN FROM. AND THEY'RE
INUNDATED WITH IT.
LIKE AVENAL STATE PRISON.
IT'S A MODEL.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD SAY.
THE WARDEN MISS ROSEMARY INDO
MADE SURE. THAT EVERY CORNER YOU
TURN THERE WAS SOME KIND OF
VOLUNTEER OUR FACILITATOR OUR
GROUP. THAT WAS TEACHING YOU
ABOUT YOURSELF DAY EMOTIONAL
INTELLIGENCE THAT ONE NEEDS IN
ORDER TO UNDERSTAND IF A CHILD
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND. WHAT DOES IT
DO?
IF I DON'T DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
DOES IT DO IT ASK QUESTIONS
NOT A CHILD A CHALLENGES ACTS
OUT.
SO IF YOU CAN FIND A WAY TO GET.
ANOTHER STAFFING.
WHEN I SAY THAT.
BASED ON THE ABBOTT NO
STATEMENT IF YOU CAN FIND A WAY.
TO GET IT WHERE EVERY CUANDO
THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TURN.
THEIR FACE WITH.
THIS IS WHAT THE PROBLEM WAS.
AND TREATING WIT LOVE INSTEAD OF
YOU KNOW MASS INCARCERATION IN A
GM IT LOOKS LIKE A HOMELESS
SHELTER.
I THINK THIS WOULD. WORK MUCH
BETTER IT WORK FOR ME.
INTO WHEN THEY TOLD ME THAT SOME.
MY BEHAVIOR WAS BASED ON ME
BEING MOLESTED AS A CHILD.
IN THEY PUT THE PIECES OF THE
PUZZLE TOGETHER FOR ME.
THEY'RE NOT STARTED TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN THEY EXPLAINED
TO ME THE IMPORTANCE OF A
MISSING FATHER IN MY LIFE.
HOW IT ACTUALLY AFFECTED ME AS A
YOUNG ADULT?
DID IT MADE SENSE
I WOULD PRISON AT. EIGHTEEN
YEARSOLD I GOT OUT WHEN I WAS.
FIFTY FIFTY THREE YEARS OLD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
AS ANY INFORMATION FROM.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
BELIAU.
OKAY.
.
ANY ANY INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO MAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
YES MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THIS IS INTERESTING BUT
I HAVE.
I WILL LOOK A LITTLE BIT BIGGER
PICTURE.
THE AT AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
THIS I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THAT WE NEED TO DO IN
CALIFORNIA'S LOOK AT THE OVERALL
SYSTEM.
AND SEE WHAT OPPORTUNITIES WE
HAVE TO BETTER SERVE KIDS WHO
GET IN TROUBLE FOR WHATEVER
REASON I THINK YOU YOU BRING UP
A VERY GOOD POINT ABOUT. KIND OF
CAUSATION WHICH WE REALLY
HAVEN'T GOTTEN TO.
SO IF WE REDESIGN THE SYSTEM
SOME OF THE IDEALS WOULD BE
KEEPING GETS CLOSER TO HOME BUT
ALSO MEANS.
DIVERTING KIDS INTO ALTERNATIVE
PROGRAMS WHERE THEY CAN GET
SERVICES.
AND SO I THINK WHAT WE NEED TO
BE CAREFUL OF THE SEVERAL THINGS.
AND ONE IS.
THE WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
THIS FITS INTO A BROADER
STRATEGY FOR ADDRESSING THOSE
ISSUES IN SOME COUNTIES ARE
DOING A VERY GOOD JOB OF. TRYING
TO DIVERT KIDS.
TRYING TO SOLVE THEIR ISSUES
THAN OTHERS AREN'T.
AND SO IF WE'D BRING THE FOCUS
WHICH I WOULD AGREE WITH BACK
MORE TOHAVE TREMENDOUS CAPACITY
IN JUVENILE HALLS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SO INSTEAD OF GOING
TO THE STATE LEVEL KIDS ARE
CLOSER TO HOME.
THAT'S A PLUS.
BUT IF WE CREATE.
BEDS
WE TEND TO WANT TO FILL THEM.
AND THAT MIGHT LEAD US TO A
WRONG CONCLUSION THAT A WE HAVE
THE BEDS LET'S. LOCK MORE KIDS
UP THE NOT SO WE HAVE TO BE WARY
OF THAT.
AND I THINK FOR THOSE KIDS TO DO
GET LOCKED UP I ABSOLUTELY WOULD
AGREE THE PROGRAMMING.
THE SERVICE IS PROVIDING THAT.
IT A CORRECT SPACE IS HIGHLY
CRITICAL. BUT I WOULD ALSO NOT
ONE IS THEN TO LEAD TO THAT
DIRECTION THAT WE HAVE ALL THESE
GREAT FACILITIES SO WE NEED TO
LOCK THE KIDS UP TO HELP THEM.
WHEN THE INITIAL. INQUIRY SHOULD
BE SHOULD THIS CHILD BE LOCKED
UP.
SHOULD THE SHALL BE DIVERTED ARE
THERE OTHER PROGRAMS WHICH WE
ALSO HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
CREATE IN THE COMMUNITY.
GET THEM TO THE PROGRAM SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT IN A JUVENILE
SETTING. THOSE KIDS WHO DO NEED
TO GO TO JUVENILE HALL SETTING
THEN THIS KIND OF APPROACH IS
ABSOLUTE PROGRAM FAR PREFER. TO
TO WHAT WE HAVE DONE.
SO WE HAVE TO BE I THINK
COGNIZANT OF. DAY INCENTIVES
THAT WERE SETTING UP AND
ENSURING THAT THAT COUNTIES ARE
PROVIDING.
A HEALTHIER WAY OF LOOKING AT
HOW THEY'RE DOING JUVENILE
JUSTICE SO IF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IN AND I KNOW YOU YOU BEAR. A
MUCH GREATER BURDEN THAT A LOT
OF OTHER JUST BECAUSE A
POPULATION THAT A LOT OF OTHER
COUNTIES.
BUT ALSO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
WE'RE NOT SENDING THE MESSAGE TO
OTHER COUNTIES. CREATE FANCY
LOOKING FACILITIES AND JUST LOCK
UP MUCH KIDS UP BECAUSE THAT
ALSO WORKS AGAINST
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO.
TO CREATE HERE SO THERE'S
THERE'S A BIT OF A BALANCE UP
I'M ACTUALLY VERY INTERESTED IN
THIS IN INTERESTED IN IN WHAT
YOU'RE DOING BUT I THINK. BIGGER
PICTURE WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT.
OVERALL WHERE WE WANT TO DO REAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TO GO HOW WE CAN
BETTER BENEFIT THOSE KIDS THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
IN A HEALTHY WAY IF THEY ARE
GOING TO BE LOCKED UP.
ABSOLUTELY PROGRAMMING SERVICES.
AN ENVIRONMENT CONDUCIVE. TO
FIXING THE ISSUES NEED TO BE
FIXED AND GETTING THEM BACK OUT
OF THE COMMUNITY HEALTH WOOD
BECAUSE THEN THEY DON'T RESEARCH
BUT THEY DON'T COME BACK THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BE THE ADULT
CRIMINALS.
THAT'S A HUGE WIN.
BUT WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO
PRESUME GOT A GREAT FACILITY SO
LET'S
WALK UP MORE KIDS THAT THAT'S
GOING TO BE A TEMPTATION THAT I
DO WORRY ABOUT JUST KNOWING.
BUT YOU BUT KNOWING KNOWING
SYSTEMS.
SO THAT IT'S GOOD THAT THINK
THAT WE'RE TAKING THIS UNDER
CONSIDERATION AND AND SEE WHAT
WE CAN REALLY DO ENCOURAGE.
THINKING ALONG THIS LINE BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO HAPPEN I OF THE
BIGGER SYSTEM.
HOW THIS FITS INTO WHERE WE
SHOULD BE GOING AND AND HOW WE
CAN LEVERAGE WAR?
JOB BEST PRACTICES SO THAT OTHER
COUNTIES KIND OF COME.
AND IT WAS JUST.
JONES SAWYER. UMBRAGE SO RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A.
DIGITAL BID DEBATE GOING ON
MIKE'S MIKE MEMBERS THAT IT OF
KIND OF.
.
THAT THIS.
BUT IDEA OF WHAT THE CLOSE
PRISONS OR REPURPOSED.
AND IT'S
KIND OF.
WHAT KIND OF DEBATING AT RIGHT
NOW YOU NEED ENOUGH FORTUNATE
FEES AND DIVERT DOING IN REAL
TIME?
I DO BELIEVE THAT ENVIRONMENT
MATTERS AND I AND I AND I THINK.
S. MAN FOR COMING HERE BECAUSE
HISTORIAS.
IS PROBABLY.
IF NOT ALL OF THE GOOD MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN LOCKED UP.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT
IF THEY'VE EXPERIENCE A
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCE
ARE A LIKE TO STATE A
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS DISORDER
THAT DAY EXPERIENCE.
AND THEIR HOME LIFE THAT
ENVIRONMENT AND IN A GET.
THE JUVENILE FACILITY.
AND IT SOME WAYS IT TRAINS YOU
THE MOVE ON INTO THE
PENITENTIARY. AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE HEARING FROM
COLLEAGUES WE DON'T WANT TO SET
UP. ON A SITUATION WHERE.
.
ADMINISTRATION IS IT IS NOT
WORKING REAL HARD TO PUT
THEMSELVES OUT OF BUSINESS.
AND IT AND INSTEAD OF TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THAT THE STATUS QUO IN
TRYING TO MAINTAIN.
A THRIVING INDUSTRY OF PRISON
INDUSTRY AND AND SO I I MADE.
I AM A FIRM BELIEVER THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO COME UP WITH THE
WAY.
FIGURE OUT THIS BALANCE BETWEEN
CLOSING AND REPURPOSE.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A REAL GOOD
DISCUSSION ABOUT REPURPOSE.
AND AND SO FORTH IF WE COULD
SHOW NOT ONLY THAT REPURPOSE
SING WORKS.
ON A ON A FACILITY THAT USED TO
BE SHAPE FROM WHITE BUT ALSO ROI.
YOU WOULD PROBABLY SPEND WHAT
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER. JUVENILE.
AND I'VE ALWAYS SAID WE COULD
SEND SOMEONE TO S. C. FOR REASON
FOR KIDS DESI.
YOU CAN SEND A EIGHT KIDS UCLA A
FULL SCHOLARSHIP EACH YEAR.
.
RECEIVE A.
SO WE'D DEFTLY PROGRAMMING BUT
THIS WHOLE NEW COUNT THIS
CONCEPT THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THAT ENVIRONMENT.
MATTERS.
.
YOUR BRITAIN TO DISCOUNT A NEW
US AND SO IF YOU COULD ALSO SHOW.
ON A RETURN ON INVESTMENT THAT
FOR EVERY.
AVERAGE YOUNG PERSON THAT COMES
INTO THE FACILITY THAT DOESN'T.
END UP IN THE PRISON SYSTEM
THERE IS A. WE CAN QUANTIFY THAT.
AND IF WEEK I WAS IN FRONT OF
HIM KEEP YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
COMING IN ORDERED THEIR STATE IS
A LOT SHORTER BECAUSE THEY GET
ALL THE. THE NECESSARY TO HELP
THEY NEED.
I SIGNATURE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PER YOUNG PERSON PERSON IF THEY
DON'T HAVE TO SAY STATER THREE
OR FOUR YEARS AND SO ON.
I WHAT WOULD IT COURAGE YOU DID
TO TRY TO BRING THOSE NUMBERS
LIKE THAT
BECAUSE I ALSO BELIEVE THAT. IF
THE FUTURE LOVE UP.
REHABILITATION A FUTURE OF
CORRECTIONS
IT'S. PUTTING THEMSELVES OUT OF
BUSINESS.
BUT ALSO SHOWING THE TAXPAYER
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT REALLY.
ONBOARD. WHICH REHABILITATION
THAT.
PEOPLE WHO USE THOSE TERMS
THAT WE ALL DON'T.
LIKE TO USE.
THAT YOU CAN'T.
.
YOU CAN'T SAVE EVERYONE.
THAT'S TRUE BUT WE PROBABLY SAVE
A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE WOULD
PROBABLY SAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
MONEY.
SO IF YOU.
HOW TO QUANTIFY THAT I THINK IT
MAKES IT EASIER TO IT TO LOVE
INVEST?
USE TERMS LIKE INVESTED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN A BRAND NEW
FACILITY. DIDN'T TO SHOW THAT
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT WILL BE
AT SOME OUT AND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION FROM YOU OR BILLION
DOLLARS YOU COULD SAVE. OVER TEN
YEARS AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHY WERE MADE JUST KIND
OF INVESTMENT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS IN ANY OTHER
MEMBERS COMMENTS YOU MAY HAVE
FOR ONE LAST BRIEF COMMENT ON I
JUST WANTED I ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE AND RESPONSE YOUR COMMENTS
ON THAT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER IS WHILE. I THINK.
THAT THE CHIEFS CERTAINLY
COMPLETELY SHARE.
EXACTLY WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM MY NOT WANTING THIS TO BE
IN LIEU OF.
DIVERSION ON THE FRONT END AND
SO.
GOT CERTAINLY WOULD NOT BE OUR
INTENT AND WE WOULD WANT TO WORK
I THINK VERYDILIGENTLY TO MAKE
SURE THAT ISN'T HAPPENING.
AT AS I MENTIONED NINETY
PERCENT OF THE YOUTH IN THE
COUNTY SYSTEM ARE ACTUALLY
ARGUED TO BE DIVERTED INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
BEFORE THAT SMALL POPULATION
THAT IS LEFT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE GIVING THEM THE BEST
ABILITY WHILE IN THE HALL AND SO.
AM I JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS.
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD.
ABSOLUTELY WANT TO EAT AT THAT
THAT WE SHARE AND WOULD WANT TO
WORK ON WITH THE OF.
I HAVE ONE THING AS WELL SO IN
THE RETURN ON INVESTMENT I AGREE
I THINK WE HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE EXPECT OR
BEING DRIVEN NOT JUST BY PROGRAM
BUT DESIGNED SO KILPATRICK. FOR
EXAMPLE ARE ARKAN FLAGSHIP OF
THE NEW LA MODEL.
ALL OF THE METRICS EARLY ON WERE
RESEARCHING INDEPENDENT OF US
CHAU MUCH BETTER OUTCOMES IN
THAT CAMP THAN OTHER CAMPS USED
ON YOUTH VIOLENCE USED
ENGAGEMENT YOUTH COMPLETIONS OF
CLASSROOMS. BECAUSE THEY FEEL
SAFE THEY FILLING GAUGE THEY
FEEL LIKE EVERY TORN. CORNER
THEY TRONG SOMEBODY THEIR CARES
ABOUT HIM SO I BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT DESIGN OF THAT FACILITY
WILL DEMONSTRATE COUPLED WITH
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED WITHOUT
PROGRAM DOESN'T DOESN'T DO IT
EITHER. WILL DEMONSTRATE THAT
THAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
JUVENILE DETENTION IN AMERICA.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS AND OF
MY COLLEAGUES AND AND OTHERS
CLEARLY.
.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WE'RE AT A
DIFFERENT PLACE AND WE WERE A
FEW YEARS AGO. THAT WE HAVE
REDUCED THE NUMBER OF YOUNG
PEOPLE AND JUVENILE HALLS AND IN
THE VARIOUS.
LOCKED UP FACILITIES THAT IS
VERY VERY ENCOURAGING I THINK.
EVEN BEFORE YOU CAME WE LOOKED
AT THAT WE LOOK BEEN LOOKING AT
THE NUMBERS AND SEEING THE
DRAMATIC DECREASE IN THE NUMBER
OF YOUNG PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
LOCKING UP. AND THE KIND OF
DIVERSION OR PROGRAMS THAT EXIST
AS WELL AS TRYING TO PUT THEM IN
DIFFERENT PLACES SO THEY WILL
GET BETTER OUTCOMES THAT NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT WE WANT
BETTER OUTCOMES. NOT JUST THE
FINANCIAL REASONS BUT FOR THE
MORE HUMAN REASON THAT PEOPLE'S
LIVES NEED TO BE ENHANCED AND
THEY DIDN'T GAUGE AND ACTIVITIES
FOR REASONS.
BUT WE SHOULD BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO REHABILITATE.
INDIVIDUALS AND AND WE CAN LIVE
FOR MINDFUL OF WHAT WE DO
SEPARATE SAY WHAT YOU DOING
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS VERY
CAREFULLY.
CLEARLY WE KNOW WE HAVE TO
REPURPOSE THESE FACILITIES
BECAUSE JUST THE STRUCTURE OF
THE FACILITIES HIMSELF IS NOT IS
NOT CONDUCIVE. FOR THE RESULTS
THAT WE WANT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
AND DOES SO I APPRECIATE YOU
COMING APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU DON'T. THANK YOU FOR GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY.
THERE ARE MANY MANY WHO HAVE
SIMILAR TESTIMONIES
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT.
WE PLANNED TO DO BETTER AND WE
COMMIT OURSELVES TO DOING BETTER
SO THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
BECAUSE SO MUCH OF WHAT WE THINK.
THAT BRINGS US TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO LANGUAGE ACCESS PLAN
AUGMENTATION I'M GOING TO TURN
THE MEETING OVER TO MR STONE I
CAN.
BECAUSE I HAVE TO ATTEND
ANOTHER MEETING CONSERVATIVE
BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
SO MS WEBER LETS ME RUN THE
MEETING BUT.
SHE MADE IT CLEAR I DON'T GET TO
MAKE ANY OF THE DECISIONS.
WHICH IS APPROPRIATE OKAY
LANGUAGE ACCESS PRINT PLAN
JUDICIAL COUNCIL YES I.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON SLOT CHO FEW
GARBAGE THE BUDGET DIRECTOR FOR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL. I'M AND
I'M HERE TO BRIEFLY. GIVE YOU AN
OVERVIEW OF THE LANGUAGE ACCESS
PROPOSAL THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
NAY REVISION.
THE BUT THE BRANCH REQUEST A
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION TO ADDRESS.
OTHER ISSUES OUTSIDE OF DIRECT.
SERVICE FOR AYE LANGUAGE ACCESS
ON A VERY CRITICAL ASPECTS OF
OUR LIVES COMPREHENSIVE LANGUAGE
ACCESS PLAN THAT WE ARE REALLY
APPRECIATE SEEING IN THE BUDGET.
IT REFLECTS.
A NUMBER OF CORE AREAS THAT WE
NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND IN
PARTICULAR THERE'S FUNDING FOR
SIGNAGE AT ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS.
THERE IS A NEED AS FAR AS.
GETTING FOLKS AS THEY ENTER THE
COURT.
KNOWING WHERE THEY CAN ACTUALLY
ACCESS SERVICES.
THERE'S ALSO A PROPOSAL I
RELATED TO COURT INTERPRETER
CREDENTIALING REVIEW ANOTHER
ASPECT OF OUR LANGUAGE ACCESS
PLAN IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY AND
ACCURACY OF THE SKILLS AND. OF
THE INTERPRETERS.
THERE'S TRAINING WITH FIND THAT
THAT TO BE A IMPORTANT ASPECT OF.
LANGUAGE ACCESS ENSURING THAT
THE INTERPRETERS ARE I'M FULLY
TRAINED ON THE SPOT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND THERE IS A INFRASTRUCTURE
AND EQUIPMENT AGAIN ANOTHER
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THE THE
PROPOSAL FOR ABOUT A MILLION AND
A HALF DOLLARS I'M RELATED TO
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS A MULTI
LINGUAL DEVICES AND SELF HELP
CENTER SO THEY WERE. LOOKING TO
CREATE THAT NEXUS THERE AS FAR
AS LANGUAGE ACCESS IN OTHER
ASPECTS OF THE COURT. ON KIOSKS.
INTERPRETER QUITMAN SUCH AS
UPGRADED HEADSETS FOR THAT FOR
THE INTERPRETERS TO BE ABLE TO
DO THEIR WORK.
MULTILANGUAGE COMMUNICATION OR
FINDING THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
PROVIDE.
VIDEOS.
IN MANY OF MULTIPLE LANGUAGES.
AND SO THAT'S CRITICAL AND THEN
FINALLY WE HAVE A NECESSARY
STAFF TO.
SUPPORT THE.
THOUGH DICK EXPANDED LANGUAGE
ACCESS PROPOSED PROGRAM I'M TO
ENSURE ITS SUCCESS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OWN FINANCE REALLY OF
ANY.
THINK YOU'RE BACK IN HER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE JUST WANT
TO REITERATE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
CONTINUES AND BUILDS UPON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT. TO
PROVIDE FOR LANGUAGE ACCESS IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS.
I. THINK I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM
.
WITH THE HERNANDEZ STRATEGY
GROUP ON THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS.
WE JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THE ITEM HERE OR NOT.
AS IT RELATES EQUIPMENT HERE IN
THEIR REQUEST I'M ISN'T USED FOR
THINGS LIKE SPANISH AND FRESNO
OR PROVIDING INTERPRETERS WHERE
WE HAVE IN PERSON LIVE
INTERPRETERS AVAILABLE. THAT
IT'S ONLY USED TO FILL THAT
SMALL GAP WHERE WE HAVE A
LANGUAGE WHERE THERE'S NOT AN
INTERPRETER AVAILABLE.
AND THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO IF
YOU'RE AYE BY FIRST APPEARANCE.
AB BY VIDEO REMOTE SO WE JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
ITEM IS.
IS CLEAR. ANYWHERE ELSE I CAN
ADDRESS THAT.
IT WOULD ALSO A PUBLIC COMMENT.
RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM.
COMMITTEE.
SIGH EC COUPLE AND ONE IS
WHY NOW. IS THIS BEING BROUGHT
FORWARD DID THIS COMES FROM.
THE LANGUAGE ACCESS STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT GOES BACK A FEW YEARS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING THROUGH THE
BUDGET. SO WHAT IF IT'S JUST
WHEN THE TIMING OF THIS ISSUE
WORKING WITH VOTE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST. NEEDS HAVE BEEN THE
ACTUAL DIRECT ACCESS AND
EXPANSION INTO SEVERAL.
WHILE THESE HAVE BEEN A SORT OF
ONGOING NEEDS IN THE DEN IF I
NEED TO THINK IT WAS JUST A AN
IMPORTANT MOMENT FOR THAT THE.
ADMINISTRATION TO REFLECT AND
THIS IN THE BUDGET FOR US OKAY
AND THEN IF YOU WOULD ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE THIS IS
THIS IS AN ONGOING DEBATE. THAT
COMES THROUGH VARIOUS COMMITTEES
PUTTING MY OWN ABOUT.
RELIANCE ON ELECTRONICS VERSUS
INDIVIDUALS ESPECIALLY WHERE WE
HAVE THOSE RESOURCES AND AND WE
WE DO HAVE THE VIDEO REMOTE
INTERPRETING PILOT. IN PROGRESS
AND SO THIS IS THIS HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH ANY EXPANSION OR AND
CONTEMPLATED EXPANSION WE ARE
COMMITTED TO COMPLETING THAT
MANY AND DETERMINING ITS VALUE
TO THE PROGRAM.
SO THIS IS ONLY FOR CURRENT.
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST IN THE IN
THE COURTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
LUMP.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO HOLD THIS
ITEM OPEN.
SO WE WILL DO SO.
THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS JUDICIAL
BRANCH CAPITAL OUTLAY.
MOST CHAIR AROUND THE HEAD AND
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES A NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL LEASE
REVENUE BOND AUTHORITY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF FIVE
COURTS.
GLAND RIVERSIDE SACRAMENTO
CINEMA AND STANISLAUS YOU CAN
SEE THE SPECIFIC BUDGETS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED THEIR.
THESE OH FIVE PROJECTS WERE
PART OF THE ORIGINAL GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL IN ANTICIPATED A
FOR.
FUNDING IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET THAT THEY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
ACCELERATE AVAILABILITY. INTO
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL
YEAR AND WE DO HAVE INFORMATION
AS FAR AS ANTICIPATED
CONSTRUCTION DATES AND
COMPLETION DATE SO WE CAN
PROVIDE COMMITTEE IF THAT'S.
DESIRED.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
BUT IT.
ANY AND WITH IT WE HAVE MY CORNY
HERE THE DIRECTOR OF OUR
FACILITIES PROGRAM THE EVENT
THEY HAVE SOME MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS ARE. PERFECT
SO THE TROUT FINANCE.
THERE'S NO SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
WHERE WE COME AT THIS TIME.
OKAY AND THEY'LL THEY'LL.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING REJECTING
THEM A REVISION PROPOSAL.
WE FOUND THAT IT WAS PREMATURE
TO PROVIDE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
WITH THIS AUTHORITY.
AS A NUMBER OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE LIKELY TO BE IN PRE
CONSTRUCTION DESIGN ACTIVITIES
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. FOR EXAMPLE
THE JANUARY PROPOSAL INCLUDES
THIRTY TWO POINT TWO MILLION FOR
THREE OF THE FIVE PROJECTS FOR
PRE CONSTRUCTION DESIGN
ACTIVITIES.
THE OTHER THING THAT WE WOULD
NOTE IS THAT WE STILL CONTINUE.
AS WAS HEARD IN A PRIOR HEARING
TO RECOMMEND THE BROADER CHANGES
EITHER OVERHAULING THE COURT
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM OR
MODIFYING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
KEY UNDERLYING ISSUES.
THANK YOU. ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
HANG ON A SECOND WE WOULD.
GOOD MORNING CARE ALSO BEHALF OF
THE CITIES OF SACRAMENTO IN
SANTA ROSA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THEM A REVISION. PROPOSAL WE
THINK THESE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
PROJECTS FOR A COMMUNITIES AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING GOING
ON THE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THE COMMISSION CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN STRONG SUPPORT A MAJOR
VERSION PROPOSAL.
ANYONE ELSE.
RIGHT SEEN NONE I DO APPRECIATE
HOW ELLIOTT WAS TECHNICALLY
ADAPTS
BAD MOVING THAT.
MICROPHONES AROUND SORRY ABOUT
THAT WE JUST DON'T SEEM TO QUITE
HAVE THE FACILITIES WORKED OUT
HERE BUT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ASSISTANCE IN THAT.
AND THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
THIS OBERNOLTE I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE LA SO I JUST WANTED TO SAY A
FEW WORDS IN SUPPORT OF THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY. BOB.
MOST OF YOU WHO KNOW ME KNOW
THAT I HAVE A GREAT PASSION FOR
QUIRK FUNDING. AYE AND IT GROWS
OUT OF EXPERIENCE I HAD WHEN I
WAS THE MAYOR OF LOSING OUR
COURTHOUSE AND SEEING OVER THE
ENSUING YEARS THE IMPACT THAT
THAT LOSS OF JUSTICE HAD ON THE
PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENTATIVE AND.
THAT IS REALLY NEVER LEFT ME.
IF YOU ASK THE AVERAGE
CONSTITUENT.
TO A SHORT LIST OF THE NUMBER OF
THE THINGS THE GOVERNMENT DOES
FOR THEM.
THE COURTS WOULD BE HIGH UP ON
THAT LIST AND A LOT OF THE
THINGS THAT GET DEBATED IN THIS
CHAMBER WOULD NOT BE HIGH UP ON
THAT LIST OF IN THAT THAT PEOPLE
REALLY CARE ABOUT.
ABOUT THEIR ACCESS TO JUSTICE
WITHOUT THAT ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THEY REALLY LOSE THEIR THEIR.
TRUST IN GOVERNMENT AS A WHOLE
SO.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE OF OUR
COURT SYSTEMS AND ALTHOUGH NONE
OF THESE FACILITIES A BENEFIT MY
DISTRICT.
IT WILL BENEFIT THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM AS A WHOLE AND SO I THINK
THERE ARE REALLY WORTHY OF
SUPPORT AND.
I CERTAINLY WILL VOTE IN FAVOR
OF THEM ENTERTAINMENT OPTION.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMITTEE
COMMENTS.
JUST WHERE I'M I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT BROWN AGAINST THERE'S
DIFFERENT TIMETABLE.
AND THERE'S SOME ARM.
OVERALL COST ESTIMATES FOR
THESE FIVE PROJECTS IN.
AND AND HOW MUCH IT WILL BE IN.
WHAT WHAT WHAT THE TAXPAYERS
ULTIMATELY?
SPEND ON THESE ON SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR.
FOR FOR QUITE SOMETIME.
AND I MEAN I'VE HAD JUDGES
CALLED ME HAVE UNIONS CALLING ME.
AND AGAIN I ASKED HIM THE SAME
THING TO HAVE TO DISTRICT
COUNCIL GET THAT INFORMATION TO
ME.
AS OF YET I'VE NOT RECEIVED
INFORMATION AND I JUST FIND IT.
THE LITTLE INSULTING.
THAT A MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
CAN'T GET ANY INFORMATION.
AND THAT I ASKED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN FORWARD AYE THERE IS A
PROBLEM.
OR EITHER YOU DON'T WANT US TO
KNOW WHAT THIS WHAT THIS WILL
COST.
AND SO THAT MAKE ME VERY
SUSPICIOUS.
GOING FORWARD ABOUT AUTHORIZING
ANY SPENDING FOR ANY COURT COSTS.
UNTIL WE KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WRITTEN
GRATEFUL TO GUARD TAXPAYERS
MONEY.
IT MONIES AND.
.
I.
I. YOU KNOW I'M ALMOST AT MY
WHICH SENATE DISAPPOINT.
SO. UNTIL I GET SOMETHING IN MY
OFFICE.
VERY SOON I'M GOING TO
RECOMMEND TO THE CHAIR.
THAT NOT ONLY WE WE FOLLOW WHAT
THE LA O. ONCE GET WE DO MAYBE A
FULL.
.
AUDIT OR A FULL UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS ENTIRE PROJECT AND HOW MUCH
WE'RE SPENDING.
AND WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE ON
TRACK WHERE THE NOT WE NEED TO
JUST TOTALLY REVAMPED THE
PROGRAM AND START OVER FROM
SCRATCH.
BECAUSE.
RIGHT NOW AS SOMEONE WHO DONE
IT BEFORE.
AS SOMEONE WHO'S DONE IT
INCORRECTLY BEFORE IN THE CITY
OF LA. YOU'RE ON THE PATH OF
WHAT WE DID IT CORRECTLY.
AND WE COST THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AND I DON'T KNOW HOW THE STATE
OPERATES
I'M IF DISSES DE THE WAY IT DOES
DAN DE MAYBE WE NEED TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION.
ABOUT HOW WE CONSTRUCT PROJECTS
AND IN THE STATE.
GOT I THINK IF YOU DID AUDIT
YOU WOULD FIND OUT THAT WOULD
PROBABLY. EXPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT.
GO TO CONTRACTORS AND DON'T GET
TOO BUILDING THE ACTUAL FACILITY
OR PROBABLY WASTING MILLIONS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT MANAGING THESE
PROJECTS EFFECTIVELY.
SO.
JIM IS I GET THAT INFORMATION
AND HAVE A DISCUSSION.
AT.
SO I'M AT MY WIT'S END PRACTICE
POINT.
THANK YOU OTHER COMMENTS.
I KNOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
THOSE COMMENTS BUT WILL WE WILL
ENDEAVOR TO GET THE INFORMATION
TO IMMEDIATELY AFFECTED LIKE MY
COPY.
AND YOU CAN HAVE A.
AHA.
OKAY LA GONNA TO THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR SURE.
THANK YOU THAT WOULD THAT WOULD
BE APPRECIATED MAKING SURE THAT
AND AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT.
ANYBODY COMING BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
SHOULD SEE A CHANGE IN IN WHAT
WE HOW WE'RE TRY TO CONDUCT
OURSELVES WITH THE LONGER VIEW
THAT WE HAVE.
THE TERM LIMIT CHANGE BEING
RESPONSIBLE TO OUTCOMES
IMPLEMENTATION IT IS IT
SOMETHING THAT. THAT WE'RE
TRACKING VERY CLOSELY AND OUR
OBLIGATION OF DOING OVERSIGHT IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO RELEARN. AND TAKE SERIOUSLY
SO ANY ASSISTANCE YOU CAN HAVE.
WHEN YOU HAVE REQUEST LIKE THIS
TO ENSURE THAT THAT WE GET THE
INFORMATION WE NEED IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU THAT ITEM AS
WELL WILL BE HELD OPEN.
WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR.
WITH THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
MICROWAVE NETWORK
.
THE DIRECTOR WELCOME GOOD
MORNING.
ALREADY.
GOING MISTER MEMBERS OF THAT
COMMITTEE HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU
THIS MORNING.
AND DOUBT AND WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF THINGS THAT.
COVER TODAY SO CALLED I'LL JUMP
RIGHT INTO A MARKET ARE DITCHING
DIRECTOR OF.
OF.
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES.
I HEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
I THINK FIRST OF ALL ITEM THAT
WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SAFETY
MICROWAVE NETWORK.
LET ME JUST FRAME THE. THE
BASELINE FOR THIS.
THIS PROGRAM.
THE THE PUBLIC SAFETY MIKE
WE'VE NETWORK IS IS REALLY THE
BACKBONE.
OF THE OF OUR COMMUNICATIONS
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IT SPANS THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND DOUBT IT IT THAT INTERACTS
WITH WITH ALL LOCAL AND STATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS
DOWN TO THE PATROL VEHICLE AND
FIRE. ENGINE LEVEL.
IT'S CRITICAL IN IN THAT IT IS
THE BACKBONE SOAK IT KEEPS THE.
THE SYSTEM OPERATIONAL THERE'S
MORE THAN FIFTY MICROWAVE UNITS
THAT ARE PART OF THAT.
ENSURES THAT WE'VE
COMMUNICATIONS BOTH ON THAT ARE
ON THE.
WEST SIDE OF THE SIERRA NEVADA
RANGE ON THE EAST SIDE IN THE
FARTHEST REACHES OF OF AYE NORTH
AND SOUTH.
HOWEVER IT IS A FIFTY YEAR OLD
SYSTEM.
OVER THE YEARS.
WE'VE BEEN.
ARE CONTINUING TO MAINTAIN IT
OUT AS WE POSSIBLY CAN BUT
REALLY.
THE MORE IMPORTANT THING IS IS
THAT IT IS AT A PLACE WHERE.
YOU KNOW TECHNOLOGY IS
OVERCOMING US.
AND OUT OF THE SYSTEM IS PRETTY
PREDOMINATE AYE ANALOG SYSTEM.
AND UNFORTUNATELY YOU KNOW WAR
FORTUNATELY I WOULD SAY WITH ALL
THE TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE. WE'RE
MOVING TO A COMPLETELY DIGITAL.
WORLD AND SO ON AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN.
A BUILDING OUT INITIATIVES LIKE
pTEXTING THAT NIGHT WHEN ONE IN
VIDEO AND I WON ONE SERVICES.
.
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT IS ALL
BIG THAT DIGITAL AYE DATA IS
BEING PUSHED OVER I'M FACT ALL
OF THE. THAT THE COMMUNICATION
SYSTEMS WILL GO FROM A VOICE TO
A A A DIGITAL.
AYE FIBER SORT OF NETWORK AT
THAT IS GONNA BE TIGHT THROUGH
THROUGH THE MICROWAVES. AND.
AND OF COURSE.
TO OTHER CREEPY AND ISSUES THE
FIRST NET BROADBAND BEING IT'S
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMERCE'S
PUBLIC SAFETY.
INTER OPERABILITY COMMUNICATION
NETWORK THAT TIES ALL AGENCIES
TOGETHER PAN.
THE EARTHQUAKE EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM THAT WE'RE WE'RE WORKING
ON A TO BE ABLE TO MOVE ALL THE
MICROWAVE SYSTEM WALL. WILL BE
CRITICAL AND ALL OF THOSE.
THOSE ITEMS SO THIS REALLY
BEGINS THAT. PROCESS HAS BEEN UP
A LONG TERM EVALUATION OF EYES
AND UP WE KNOW THAT.
THAT.
THAT ACTION.
YOU KNOW IS IS NECESSARY TO
BEGIN THAT PROCESS OF MOVING IT
FORWARD INTO THE. INTO THE NEW.
NEW YEAR'S OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
THIS THIS PROP PROJECT WILL BE.
LISHI ADDED TO UPGRADE
EFFECTIVELY AND GET US TO WHERE
WE NEED TO BE TO STAY IN FRONT
OF THE EVOLVING TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU.
THE DIFFERENT FINANCE.
I THINK YOU AMADOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND YOU WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE TIMING OF THIS PROPOSAL
IS REALLY LESS THAN IDEAL FOR
EVERYBODY GIVEN THE COMPLEXITY.
HOWEVER IT IS A CRUCIAL
COMPONENT TO THE SUCCESS OF NOT
NEXT GENERAL ONE INTO IMPROVING
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY NETWORK.
.
THANK YOU EARLIER HOWLING
CURSING AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC CONCERNS BUT AS
FINANCE NOTED THAT THE TIMING IS
A LITTLE BIT CHALLENGING THIS IS
A. PRETTY SIGNIFICANT AND ALSO
TECHNICALLY COMPLEX.
KIND OF PROPOSAL ON IT'S
DIFFICULT TO FULLY EVALUATE IN
THE RIGHT MAY REVISE PROCESS.
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
ACTIVITY BUT.
IT IS DIFFICULT TO ASSESS BOTH
THAT WHETHER THIS IS THE RIGHT
AMOUNT AND A FUNDING SOURCE IN
THIS TIME FRAME.
THANK YOU ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS ITEM.
IF WE HAD A MORE HIGH TECH
SYSTEM THIS WOULD BE EASY HAVE
THAT WE CAN HELP YOU WITH THAT
IF WE CAN. HAVE THE HIGH DON'T
KNOW IF YOU CAN HELP US.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH I'M
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE AT
ASSOCIATION OF WHEAT ONE AND I
THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS AD
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL AND WE
WANNA. AND THINK OH YES AND WHEN
I FULL SUPPORT OF THE REVISION
AND ABSOLUTELY STAND TO WORK ON
THIS AND A PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE.
THAT EVERYTHING'S UPDATED THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
RIGHT SING THAT ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING THIS I.
THINK THAT.
PUBLIC OR DO WITH TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES NOBODY'S EVER GOING TO
KNOW WHAT THE RIGHT ANSWER IS
BUT IF WE DON'T MOVE IN MOVE
WITH ALL OF OUR. LOCAL AND
REGIONAL PARTNERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO UPGRADE THE SYSTEM THEN.
BOB IS GONNA GET WORSE AS WE GO
ALONG SO WELL.
WE'LL SEE HOW THIS ONE GOES.
RECOMMENDATIONS TO HOLD THIS
OPEN SO WE WILL DO JUST THAT AND
WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE.
WHICH IS THE.
YES AGAIN THE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM.
YEAH THIS STUFF THIS PROGRAM IS.
HAVE BEEN PLACE FOR SOME TIME
AND AND THIS IS REALLY.
FINDING.
IN WHAT'S CALLED ANTI TERRORISM
FIND.
THAT WOULD JUST SUPPORT.
NONPROFIT.
ORGANIZATIONS TO A BILL THAT
AND.
HARDENING.
OF THEIR FACILITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS PHYSICAL.
SECURITY ENHANCEMENTS TO THESE
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ARE AT HIGHER RISK OF
POTENTIAL COMMODITY VIDEO OR
POTENTIALLY UP AYE AYE TERRORIST.
KIND OF ATTACK.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT IS A
SUPPLEMENTAL TO OF TO THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM.
THAT.
INTO INTO GAZA SEVENTEEN.
THEM THE BIJAC PROVIDE A ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION OF TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS PROGRAM.
AND.
YOU KNOW IN IN.
IN THIS YEAR WE RECEIVED OVER
HER AND SIT
A HUNDRED APPLICATIONS FOR THE
THE PROGRAM TOTALING SEVEN
MILLION.
AND AND REALLY WE WERE ONLY
ABLE TO FIND OUT ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT RECIPIENTS FOR THE TWO
MILLION CELL.
THIS ON GOING.
PROGRAM AND AND DOES SOMETHING
THAT CONTINUES TO ADDRESS.
YOU KNOW AS WE SEE CONTINUE
UNCERTAINTIES AND COMPLEXITIES
IN OUR SOCIETY.
I COULD TELL YOU THAT THE THE
THREATS ACROSS THAT. THE STATE
VARIED IN IN WAYS AND AND.
MEANS BUT.
CERTAINLY THE THE THE NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT FIT INTO THIS
CRITERIA.
AREN'T ARE NO STRANGER TO THESE
KINDS OF THREATS
SO THIS WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL
FOR.
THANK YOU OR FINANCE NO COMMENT
ALEJO.
NO CONCERNS ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC LIKE TO COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE WILL HOLD THE SIDE OF OPEN AS
WELL.
SO ITEM NUMBER SIX ALSO WITH.
YES AND THIS IS THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE OPERATIONS YEAH THANK
YOU I'M. SO THIS UP PARTICULAR.
INITIATIVE REALLY STARTED OVER
THREE YEARS AGO WHEN WE IDENTIFY
BACK THEN THE THE THE GAPS.
IN ART OUR CAPABILITIES TO DEAL
WITH THE VARIOUS KINDS OF ISSUES
THAT WE.
WE'RE FACED WITH.
AT THAT TIME.
THE LEISURE FOUND.
THE.
AREA PRE SHAPED UP THE THE NEED
TIP TO SUPPLY AS WITH SOME. ARE
RESOURCES BUT.
THEY DID NOT.
YOU KNOW SUPPLY ALL THE
RESEARCHER ACT ASKING FOR AT THE
TIME.
WITH THE.
WE STILL HAD A GAP OF.
OF TWO POSITIONS IN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OPERATIONS AND AND
SICK POSITIONS THAT ARE ARE
REGIONAL EMERGENCY OPERATIONS.
I SWAM A POINT OUT THAT THE
THAT THESE POSITIONS IN AND.
AND WE HAVE BEEN THE FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT WE HAVE FIVE SIX SUB
THE MUTUAL AID REGION'S AND.
.
WHERE WEEK WE ON THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT SIDE COORDINATE?
AND ENGAGE.
LAW ENFORCEMENT MUTUAL AID AND
AND AND DEAL WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE SHARING AND
INFORMATION SHARING IN OUR SIX.
OF FUSION CENTERS.
THAT THAT THE CENTERS ARE AND
THESE THESE.
REGIONS ARE ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURING THAT THE STATE HAS.
COMPLETE COVERAGE IN IN MOVING
A LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSETS AROUND
A BOTH PRE IN IN INFORMATION
SHARING. OUR AND.
DURING AN EVENT AND THEN IN THE
RECOVERY PHASE.
AND.
.
THIS WOULD FILL OUT THE
COMPLEMENT OF THE SEXES THAT OF
THE FOUR THAT DOUBT THAT WE WERE
ALLOCATED DRY PREVIOUSLY SO
THERE. WITH THEIR IMPORTANT.
APART POSITION SUPPORT PUBLIC
SAFETY POSITIONS THE SIX ARE
EMERGENCY REGIONAL RESPONSE IN
WRITING THIS POSITIONS THESE ARE
EMERGENCY SERVICES PERSONNEL
THAT. ARE SIGNED WE AGAIN WE
HAVE SIX MUTUALLY REGION'S THESE
FOLKS ARE.
ARE THE FOLKS THAT ARE ENGAGING
DATED DAY WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
IN OUR SIX OH REGIONAL CENTERS
AND.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
ENSURING THAT UP PLANS ARE IN
PLACE.
THAT THE OPERATIONAL CONSTRUCTS
ARE THERE SO THAT WE'VE GOT THIS
* LIKE WE HAD. LAST YEAR.
THAT THE COUNTIES CAN
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND AND THEN
THROUGH THAT RECOVERY PROCESS
INSURING THAT THAT RECOVERY AND
THAT RECOVERY.
.
INITIATIVE AYE INTEGRATES
EFFECTIVELY.
AND THAT AND THESE ARE THE
FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE GROUND
WITH THE LOCAL COUNTIES AND
CITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF THE
DISASTER.
.
NOT GOING TO SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW WE IDENTIFIED THESE
NEEDS THREE YEARS AGO THAT
THEY'RE STILL A MAJOR NEED FOR
US TODAY.
THIS PAST SUMMER THIS PAST YEAR
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
LITERALLY WHERE. WE WE YOU KNOW
WE'RE MANAGING THREE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS
SIMULTANEOUSLY.
WITHIN THE STATE WHERE
LITERALLY HAVING TO PULL PEOPLE
OUT AND FLY THEM AROUND MOVE
THEM AROUND THEY WERE DEPLOYED
FOR OVER A YEAR. THESE THERE'S
THAT THE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THESE PERSONNEL WERE QUESTION.
AND AND WE JUST NEED TO GET
THESE FOLKS TO APLACE WHERE WE
HAVE THE ADEQUATE RESOURCES TO
THEM.
TO.
PROVIDE THE SERVICES ARE THESE
ARE PUBLIC SAFETY POSITIONS.
I KNOW THAT THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO DO A LIMITED TERM THE
PROBLEM IS THESE ARE PUBLIC
SAFETY POSITION SELF I WANT TO.
BRING ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
PERSONNEL FIRST OF ALL ABSENTEES
LEAVING THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY HAS TO KNOW THAT THERE
THERE'S A A CAREER PATHWAY FOR
THEM AND THAT THEY'RE. THEY'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THEIR THEIR THEIR
ORGANIZATION TO COME TO WORK FOR
THE STATE.
THEN THERE'S THE WHOLE BEYOND
THE RECRUITMENT.
THAT THEY'RE SO HOPE BACKGROUND
WHICH TAKES ALMOST A YEAR TO DO.
AND THAT WE DON'T ALL HAVE A
FOR A YEAR SO I I WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET ANYBODY TO APPLY.
THE SAME EMERGENCY SERVICES.
AREA.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE REQUIREMENT
FOR THE SITE POLYGRAPH AND
WEAPONS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT DO
BUT THEY HAVE ALL THE OTHER
ASPECTS. AND.
AND AND AND REALLY DOESN'T DO
AS MUCH COULD ONLY DO THIS FOR
FOR TWO YEARS WE WOULD REALLY
NEED THESE PEOPLE FOR THE LONG
TERM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PART OF FINANCE.
I WHAT WE'RE WE AGREE WITH ALL
THOSE COMMENTS THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT TO ASSESS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF ON GOING
STAFFING NEEDED FOR THAT
DEPARTMENT.
.
THE DIFFICULTY THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT IT'S HARD TO PREDICT WHAT
DISASTERS ARE GOING TO OCCUR AND
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO
RESPOND TO THEM AND WE THINK
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS PROVIDED
SUFFICIENT JUSTIFICATION. I'M
NOT ONLY PREVIOUSLY BUT NOW FOR
THIS PROPOSAL AND THAT'S WHY
WE'RE CONTINUING TO SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU ELIA.
SO WE'VE RAISED CONCERNS IN THE
PAST ABOUT CHALLENGES.
IN IDENTIFYING IN JUSTIFYING
THESE ADDITIONAL STAFF AYE WE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND.
BACK ESPECIALLY.
FROM THE NATURE OF THESE TYPES
OF POSITIONS.
AND A LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT WE HAVE TO ASSESS IT WHILE
WE DO RECOMMEND THAT YOU YEAR
LIMITED TERM WHICH WOULD ALLOW.
AYE THE LEGISLATURE TO REVISIT
STAFF AND WHEN THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF TIME AND
AND PERHAPS ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU A MEMBER THE PUBLIC.
SINGER AND BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
WE WILL TAKE IT UNDER ADVISEMENT
AND HOLD THE ITEM OPEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN OR
ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN. WHICH IS
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAM
WORKLOAD INCREASED RIGHT SO THE
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAM.
IS.
IS A PROGRAM THAT GETS
IMPLEMENTED.
AFTER DISASTERS.
OCCUR EMERGENCIES OCCUR.
AND DOWN AND THIS PROGRAM
REALLY IS IS FOCUSED THAT.
TAKING.
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
DISASTERS THAT WE'VE SEEN THE
KIND OF DAMAGE THAT HAS OCCURRED.
AND AND PUTTING IN PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD.
UP BY DOWN FUTURE.
IMPACTS OF OF.
OF DISASTERS.
IT'S IT'S BROUGHT IN ITS.
IT IT'S.
APPLICATION OF THERE'S A NUMBER
OF PROGRAMS THAT IT CAN BE.
I UTILIZED FOR BUT REALLY.
THE KEY THE KEY ISSUE IS TO
REDUCE.
DISASTER LOSSES PROTECT LIFE
AND PROPERTY.
FROM FUTURE DISASTERS NOW.
CALIFORNIA HAS A.
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN.
IN IN THE IN THE FEDERAL SYSTEM.
A TYPICALLY FEMALE.
WHEN THEY PROVIDE DISASTER
FUNDS PROVIDES.
UP TO FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
TOTAL COST OF A DISASTER TO A
STATE.
AYE IN HAZARD MITIGATION FIVE
BUT BECAUSE OUR PLAN.
IS WHAT'S CONSIDERED ENHANCE
PLAN THAT BECAUSE IT'S JUST IT'S
JUST THEY BUT WE GOT A REALLY
GOOD JOB WITH OUR PLAN.
FEMALE WILL PROVIDE IS UP TO
TWENTY PERCENT OF.
OF THE COST OF THE DISASTER
SO FOR THE SERIES OF THIS ASKED
WE STE WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST.
TWO YEARS.
THAT EQUATES TO OVER SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND.
HAZARD MITIGATION FUNDS THAT
ARE COMING IN FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YOU'RE COMING AND.
YES AND THE WORKLOAD.
TO BE ABLE TO.
TO MANAGE THESE THE THE SPEECH
PROGRAMS FROM FROM THE BEGINNING
ALL THE WAY TO THE AND TO GET
THEM IMPLEMENTED IN ENSURE FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MONITORING.
IS A FEW SUBSTANTIAL AND THIS
PROPOSALS ASKING FOR BROWN.
FOR ASSISTANCE IN THAT AREA.
THANK YOU PRONE FINANCE.
I AM I THINK THE LA WAS
EXPRESSED SOME CAN INTEREST IN
USING THIS HOUSING MITIGATION
FUNDING NOT NECESSARILY IN THIS
PROPOSAL BUT THE AMOUNT THAT
WE'RE GETTING FROM THE FEDS.
IN USING IT FOR A STATE
PROJECTS THAT ARE ONGOING NOW
ARE THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED TO.
I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT AND TO
THE EXTENT WE CAN USE THAT
FEDERAL MONEY WE WILL.
BUT FOR THE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS
I THINK MY RESPONSES ARE PRETTY
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA BUT.
TO THE EXTENT WE CAN USE THAT
WE WELL BUT FOR THE PROJECTS I
THINK.
FOR THESE SPECIFIC ONCE WE CAN'T.
THANK YOU AND ELIA.
SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS ON THE STAFF AND
FUNDING THAT'S PROPOSED HERE AS
FINANCE MENTION OUR COMMENT WAS
JUST A FLAG FOR THE LEGISLATURE
THAT THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
INFLUX OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
EXPECTING I'M PERHAPS SIX
HUNDRED MILLION.
THERE ARE SOME SOME PRIORITIES
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE
FOR SPENDING THOSE FUNDS.
BECAUSE THEY CAN GO TO MITIGATE
SOME OF THESE KINDS OF RISKS
WHILE THE CPAS IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE SPECIFIC. ON ACTIVITIES THAT.
THEY'RE PROPOSING THE MAY
REVISE MAY NOT BE OUT OF
ELIGIBLE FOR SOME TECHNICAL
REASONS.
SOME THE GENERAL TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES CAN INCLUDE THINGS
RELATED TO.
REDUCING UP OF FLOOD RISK FIRE
RISK SOME OF THE KINDS OF RISK
THAT THE LEGISLATURE KNOWS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT. I'M SO YOU
THINK IT'S WORTH ON THE
LEGISLATURE CONTINUING TO
EXPLORE OF WHETHER IT HAS
PRIORITIES FEES FINES AND IF SO.
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE REFLECTED.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC.
SEEING NONE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT
YEAH THIS ITEM I THINK IT'S
PRETTY WELL LAID OUT AND WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD IT OPEN AS WELL
THANK YOU I DO ISSUE NUMBER
EIGHT.
WHICH IS RECOVERY PROGRAM
WORKLOAD INCREASE YEAH AGAIN.
SO THE OTHER PART OF OUR OUR
DISASTER RECOVERY.
BRANCH.
OPERATIONS IN INCLUDES THE
ACTUAL RECOVERY.
FROM THESE DISASTERS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
WITH THREE CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
OUT LAST YEAR AND THEN.
THE PREVIOUS YEAR TWO THOUSAND
AND SIXTEEN WE HAD FIFTY TWO OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AND THE
FEDERAL DISASTER. AYE
DESIGNATION.
DUE TO THE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF RAINFALL AND AND
FLOODING WE HAD. A LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE DAMAGE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND AND GOING ALL THE WAY BACK
TO THE VALLEY INN AND BUTTE
FIRES OUT WHICH ARE FEDERAL
DISASTERS AND AND I A WHOLE LIST
OF. OF STATE ONLY DISASTER
THEY'D ONLY DISASTERS ARE
DISASTERS THAT ARE UP ABOVE THE
THE CAPABILITY OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BOB BUT BELOW THE
ABILITY TO GET FEDERAL DISASTER
AID THERE'S A WHOLE. PLETHORA OF
THOSE.
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT WE DEAL
WITH THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AS A RESULT OF ALL THOSE ARE
NUMBER OF OF PROGRAMS THAT NEED
TO BE.
I ADDRESS THIS IS DIRECTLY
WORKING WITH YOUR CONSTITUENTS
YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO ENSURE
THAT ISSUES LIKE YOU KNOW ROADS
AND PUBLIC FACILITIES AND PARKS
AND.
OTHER KINDS OF OF.
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS DAMAGED
OR DESTROYED IN THESE ADVANCE.
GETS REBUILT IN A VERY
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
AND SO.
BOB THERE'S A WHOLE LIST OF
PROGRAMS THAT THESE PROCS FOLKS
DO EVERYTHING FROM INSPECTING
DAMAGE FACILITIES. ARE TO
PROVIDE THE GUIDANCE ON OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND AND
HISTORIC PRESERVATION.
ASSISTING THROUGH THE AUDITING
APPEALS PROCESS TO MADE THE
REPORTS REQUIRED TO THE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AGENCY.
AND.
AND PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ACROSS THE BOARD.
SO.
THE WORKLOAD IS UNBELIEVABLE AT
THIS POINT AND.
AND.
TO TO TRY TO KEEP THIS ALL
GOING IN AND GET EVERYBODY'S
COMMUNITIES BACK UP TO WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE. I GET THE MONEY
IN PLACE.
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND CRITICAL WORK UP THE OTHER
THING THAT THESE FOLKS DO IS
HANDLE WHAT'S CALLED THE FAT THE
FEDERAL.
FIRE MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE
GRANTS.
IT'S A PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES.
FEDERAL DOLLARS AT THE FRONT
END OF A FIRE.
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO FIREFIGHTERS DURING THE.
AND COMMUNITIES DURING THE THE
FIRES OUT THOSE F. MAKES A VERY
CRITICAL AND UP BUT THERE'S A
WHOLE LIST OF.
ABOVE FEDERAL CRITERIA THAT NEED
TO BE ATTRACTED THAT WHOLE
PROCESS ALL THE WAY TO THE
REIMBURSEMENT TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
SO.
THIS IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
HEAVY WORKLOAD AND.
WE SUSPECT IT WILL BE THIS WAY
FOR A FEW YEARS TILL WE GET TO
ALL THESE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU TORN FINANCE.
HELLO.
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC WITH
COMING ON THIS ITEM.
ALRIGHT SEEING NONE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SINGER WE WILL HOLD THAT OUT OF
OPEN AND WE WILL MOVE TO ISSUE
NUMBER NINE.
WHICH IS THE REASON REGIONAL
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS RESPONSE
PROGRAM YEAH ON THIS ONE HERE OF
SO JUST SAYS UP OF OLYMPIC
CONTEXT THIS SIDE GOES BACK.
TO.
THE UC A COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN
OF THE LEGISLATURE FOUND FIT TO
PROVIDE EYES OF FINDING.
TO PROCURE UM.
SOME SPECIALIZED HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS RESPONSE UNITS ARE AND
BUILD A CAPABILITY AROUND THOSE.
A IT'S A CAPABILITY THAT DID
NOT HAS NOT EXISTED AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
WHERE WE COULD ACTUALLY COUNT
ON?
I HAD JUST MATERIALS MUTUAL AID
RESPONSE CAPABILITY OF THIS WAS
REALLY DRIVEN AT THAT TIME BY
THE AMOUNT OF OUR. OF OUR HIGH
OF VOLATILE A CRUDE OIL THAT WAS
BEING TRANSPORTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY AS YOU MAY
REMEMBER THERE ARE.
SOME MAJOR CATASTROPHIC AYE
DERAIL MATES AND FIRE EXPLOSIONS
THAT OCCUR IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE U. S. AND CANADA LOT OF
FATALITIES.
WE WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT
NOT HAVING A CAPABILITY WAS A
MAJOR GAP THAT WE HAD IDENTIFIED.
IN OUR STATES ABILITY TO
RESPOND LEGISLATURE RECOGNIZE
THAT GAVE US THE HOUSE MATERIALS PRODUCTS THAT
WERE COMING INTO THE STATE.
AND THERE WOULD BE OVER THERE
WOULD BE THIS SELF ASSESSMENT OF
FUN THAT WE WOULD COLLECT THAT
ASSESSMENT TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN THE PROGRAM. BUT TO GET
HIS JUMP STARTED BECAUSE IT WAS
AT A CRITICAL.
TIME SENSITIVE ISSUE GIVEN THE
AMOUNT OF OF A MATERIAL THAT WAS
BEING TRANSPORTED AND NOT JUST.
CRUDE OIL THERE'S A WHOLE. WHOLE
TON OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF MAJOR
HELLISH MATERIALS FROM MODERATE
TO VERY VERY EXTREME.
IN NATURE THEY GET MOVED BY
RAIL.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY.
THAT THIS WAS REALLY AN URGENCY
SO WE WERE FRONTED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS WE PROCURED
THESE SPECIALIZED UNITS.
WE BEAT BUT TRAIN THE INITIAL
TEAMS ARE THAT WE ENTERED INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH.
WELL THE PROCESS WAS TO ENTER
INTO AGREEMENTS WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO WOULD STAFF
THESE UNITS
WE REPLACE THEM STRATEGICALLY
THROUGHOUT ARE MUTUALLY REGIS IN
THE STATE. AND THE.
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT FIRE WOOD.
WOULD.
STAFF THEM AND WE WOULD PROVIDE
THEIR THEIR EQUIPMENT THE
TRAINING.
AND.
AND ALL OF THE EXERCISES.
SO WE'VE GOT SIX OF THE TWELVE
IN THE IN THE FIELD.
AND DOWN THE OTHER SIX ARE
DESTINED TO GO OUT THIS NEXT
WEEK.
AND DOUBT THAT.
.
THE COURSE DURING THE PROCESS
THE RAIL INDUSTRY SUED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE LAWSUIT IS IS
CURRENTLY. IN OF THE COURTS.
WHICH HAS THEN.
THEY PUT AN INJUNCTION OUR
ABILITY TO COLLECT A FEE.
AND SO WHILE WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS.
SORT OF MESSED UP STOPGAP WHILE
WE CAN GET THROUGH THE. THE
LEGAL.
AYE RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS.
AND THIS YEAR AND I'LL BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO KEEP THIS PROGRAM
WRITING.
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS.
TO ENSURE FOR THE FOR THE
MAINTAINING THE TRAINING.
AND THE AND THE EXERCISES OB
ONE CHALLENGE WE HAVE IS WITHOUT
THAT. ADDITIONAL FUNDING OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS ARE
APPARENT AND WILLING TO TAKE ON
THESE.
UNITS BECAUSE THEY. DON'T WANT
TO TAKE THIS SPECIALIZED
RESPONSIBILITY AND NOT BE ABLE
TO TRAIN THEIR PEOPLE HAVE
TRAINED PEOPLE THAT THE COURT
WOULD THE COURT WOULD JUST SIT
THERE.
SO.
SORTS OF A CHICKEN AND EGG
SITUATION WHERE WE NEED
FUNDING TO KEEP IT GOING.
BUT WE NEED TO KEEP GOING
BECAUSE OF THE THREAT.
AND.
AND AND THAT'S ALL ORBITING
AROUND THE THE LEGAL CHALLENGES
SO ON THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL
IS TO PROVIDE US WITH EXTRA A
STOPGAP FOR THE PERIOD TIME.
THANK YOU TORN FINANCE.
AND SO DOES THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED THERE IS UNCERTAINTY
IN HOW THIS FOR PROGRAM WE FIND
IN THE FUTURE THAT'S WHY THIS
REQUEST IS ONLY FOR THREE YEAR.
LIMITED TERM RESOURCES WHILE WE
AWAIT THE OUTCOME OF THOSE
LAWSUITS. AND I ALSO KNOW THAT
ANY PROPOSAL THAT WE SUBMIT IN
THE FUTURE FOR ONGOING COSTS
WILL INCLUDED. A PLAN FOR
FUNDING THOSE COSTS AND ALSO
PLAN TO REPAY ANY LOOKED THE
LOANS FOR TEMPERATURES THE FIRE
ENGINES.
THANK YOU ALEJO.
I SERRANO RAISING CONCERNS ABOUT
THE CONCEPT OF PROVIDING
RESOURCES ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO
SUPPORT THESE.
THESE VEHICLES WE AT THERE'S.
ONCE AGAIN VERY LITTLE TIME TO
ASSESS THE APPROPRIATE FUNDING
LEVEL AS WELL AS SEWERS I'M SO
WE'RE RECOMMENDING APPROVING
THIS ON A ONE YEAR BASIS THIS
WOULD ENSURE THAT THE STATE
COULD DEPLOY THESE VEHICLES BUT
IT WOULD ALLOW NEXT YEAR US TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH THE
BENEFIT OF. A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME.
TO GET AN UPDATE ON WHERE WE
ARE ON THE LAWSUIT AND OR TO
CONSIDER SOME OTHER POTENTIAL UP
FUNDING SOURCES SO WHEN WE
REVIEWED THIS PROPOSAL THE
ORIGINAL PROPOSAL A FEW YEARS
AGO. I'M WE NOTED THAT THERE ARE
SOME OTHER OPTIONS THAT COULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR EXAMPLE YOU COULD
PASS THIS AS A TAX RATHER THAN.
AS IF HE'S HE COULD PASS WITH A
TWO THIRDS MAJORITY.
POWERED POTENTIALLY THE FEE
COULD BE EXPANDED BEYOND RAIL ON
TO OTHER KINDS TRANSPORTATION
VEHICLES.
THAT.
CARRY HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
OBSERVER EIGHTY DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE TO
THE STATE WE THINK IT'S WORTH
REVISITING IT NEXT YEAR SO
THAT'S WHY WE RECOMMEND THAT
WHEN YOU'RE.
THANK YOU.
ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC.
SING NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
YOU MENTIONED PASSING IT IS A
TAX WITH TWO THIRDS IS IF THAT
WERE SO EASY YES RIGHT YEAH
EXACTLY WE'RE GOING TO. HOLD
THAT ITEM OF.
.
YEAH.
THANK YOU SO THAT I WILL BE HELD
AYE ISSUE NUMBER TEN SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS AND COLLABORATION
TOOLS JOB THIS SOME THIS IS A.
UP PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY THAT
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT
ACTUALLY STARTED AND WAS FUNDED
INITIALLY BY THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOMELAND SECURITY SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY. ARE IN A PARTNERSHIP
WITH US IN CALIFORNIA AIR TO
DEVELOP A CAPABILITY WAS BUILT
IN BY BY MIT LINCOLN LABS.
AND IT REALLY IT'S A IT'S A
COLLABORATIVE TOOL THAT.
THAT GIVES US.
REAL TIME INFORMATION.
AND THE ABILITY TO SHARE
INFORMATION RELATED TO.
DISASTER VANCE FIRE.
WHATEVER IT'S ALL HAZARDS AND
IT'S A REAL TIME AND IT INCLUDES
THE THE ABILITY TO MONITOR AND
AND VISUALIZE THE MOVEMENT.
AND PATH OF FIRES EVACUATION
AREA DEBRIS AREAS.
EIGHT IT SHOWS.
WITH.
THE RECENT EXPANSION OF
AUTOMATIC VEHICLE LOCATING
CAPABILITIES ON THE CAL FIRE
UNITS ON THE.
WE S. ENGINES AND ON A NUMBER
OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAPABILITIES
WE CAN SEE IN REAL TIME THE
MOVEMENT OF OF GROUND CREWS FIRE
ENGINES A LAW ENFORCEMENT
VEHICLES AND DOWN. AND
HELICOPTERS AIR AIR ASSETS UP
THIS REALLY DOES REDUCE
CONFUSION MISCOMMUNICATION IS BY.
BOB PROVIDING YOU KNOW A MAP
DISPLAY AND ALLOWING US TO TO TO
MAKE A REAL TIME DECISIONS THAT
IN THAT IN THAT TIME FRAME
THAT'S. IT'S REALLY NECESSARY.
IT SUPPORTED NOTE THAT.
YOU KNOW.
WE.
WHERE WHERE THIS THIS IS REALLY?
WERE WORKING ON.
.
ENHANCEMENTS OF THIS WE'VE KIT
WE PICKED THAT UPS FROM THE H.
S..
AND.
WE'VE HAD TO UPGRADE THE CODE
IN SOME OF THE THAT THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT TECHNOLOGY ARE BUT WE ARE
USING IT TODAY. ALL REQUIRES.
SOME ADDITIONAL CAPABILITY TIM
TO MANAGE.
IT HAS BECOME BECOME A CRITICAL
TOOL FOR US AND WE WILL BE
IMPLEMENTING UP OF A STRUCTURE
THAT FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS PROGRAM AND
RIGHT NOW WE'RE. WHERE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT
HAVE THEIR JOINING ON?
THERE WILL BE A LIKE UP.
.
A. S. SUBSCRIPTION KIND OF
SERVICE THAT WILL HELP OFFSET
THE COST OF THIS ARE IN THAT IN
THE FUTURE TELL THIS IS JUST A
REALLY IMPORTANT. SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS TOOL THAT WE WE
UTILIZE.
THANK YOU PRIVATE VIOLENCE
BELIAU.
REMEMBER THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU ARE ON ON THIS ONE AND
I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU AND NOT
SURE WHAT THIS COMMITTEES
ULTIMATELY GOING TO DO WITH THAT
BUT. WITH THE FIRES THAT HAPPEN
ACROSS STATE AND WE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION THERE'S ALL THIS
CONVERSATION NOW HOPPING ABOUT
WHAT WE DO NOW.
WITHOUT A LOT OF CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO UP FRONT
AND THE FIRE CHIEF HAVE A
PROPOSAL THAT I THINK IS GOING
THROUGH SUB THREE.
THIS KIND OF CONNECTIVITY AND
UNDERSTANDING WHERE ASSETS ARE
AND HOW TO MOVE THEM AROUND IS
ULTIMATELY.
I THINK GOING TO BE A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF A LONG TERM
SOLUTION TO. BEING ABLE TO MOVE
RESOURCES AROUND THE STATE AND
RESPOND BECAUSE THE POINT IS TO.
STOP AN ISSUE FROM GETTING BIG
FITS OF FIRE FLOOD BEFORE. TO
EXIT WE CAN.
BEFORE BECOMES SUCH A MAJOR
DISASTER AND THEN THESE ARE THE
TOOLS THAT HELP THAT HAPPENED
WAS I KNOW YOUR CONTACT WITH THE
FIRE CHIEFS AT ALL AND WE SHOULD.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A COORDINATED APPROACH TO
THIS.
AND WE'RE HAVING THE THE BROADER
DISCUSSION ABOUT ADDRESSING
SAFETY RISK MORE UP FRONT RATHER
THAN JUST CLEANING IT UP YEAH
AFTER ALL YOUR APPS AYE YOUR
SPOT ON. THIS OF COURSE WE'VE
BEEN COLLABORATING WITHOUT.
THE FIRES CHO BORED DIRECTOR
WHICH IS THE STATE'S FIRE
STANDARD SETTING ORGANIZATION
AND AND CAL CHIEFS AND METRO
CHIEFS ON THIS.
THIS IS THAT THIS IS THAT
ABILITY TO.
GO FROM A REACTIVE SYSTEM TO A
PROACTIVE SYSTEM THIS GIVES US
THAT THAT VISUAL ON THIS ON THE
FRONT END OF THE OTHER EVOLVING
CRISIS SO.
WERE HOPING THAT THIS IS THE
OUT ONE OF THOSE THOSE TOOLS IN
THE TOOLBOX RAZA MEMBER AND THEN
THAT'S WHERE MY COMIC IS.
I AGREE IN IN.
THE COUNTY THAT I COME FROM SOME
OF THOSE ARE IN PLACE NOT
COMPLETELY BUT THAT'S.
DO YOU SEE BILLY RESPONDED
URBANIZED AREA TO A FIRE THAT
STARTS.
KEEP IT FROM GETTING TOO LARGE.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN AS
WELL SO.
THANK YOU I ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN
THE.
DOES THAT TBL DISASTER RESPONSE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNTS
YEAH.
SO THIS SUB DISASTER.
A RESPONSE MERGED OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT.
IS IS GONNA BE LANGUAGE THE
TRAILER BILL IT'S CHANGED THE.
THE LANGUAGE IT IT IT SUNSETS
THAT.
REQUIREMENT OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS.
AND ALLOWS.
IT REALLY DESIGNED TO ALLOW
ODDS AT A WE AS THE GREATEST
FLEXIBILITY.
TO DEAL WITH.
A DISASTER.
PARTICULARLY OF THE MAGNITUDE
THAT WE SAW. RECENTLY.
IT ALLOWS US TO ACT QUICKLY
WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS TO.
BRING IN SPECIALIZED RESOURCES
A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR SO THE
EXAMPLE IS IS THAT DOWN.
.
YOU KNOW WE. YOU KNOW WE WE IN
THE NORTHERN COUNTIES WE.
WE HAD THE U. S. ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS BROUGHT IN TO HELP US
MANAGE THE.
MASSIVE PRE OPERATION
LARGEST A PRE OPERATION REALLY.
SINCE THE NINETEEN NO SIX
EARTHQUAKE AND.
YOU KNOW THEY ARE BROUGHT AND
PRIVATE CONTRACTORS IN AND ALONG
THE WAY THERE. THEIR PRIVATE
CONTRACTORS AND THE U. S.
GOVERNMENT GOT INTO A LABOR
DISPUTE WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY
HAVE SHUT DOWN DEBRIS CLARETT'S
OPERATIONS FOR NINETY DAYS AT A
MINIMUM.
THEREBY PUSHING BACK OUR
ABILITY TO GET THOSE COMMUNITIES
CLEANED UP AND RECOVERING
GETTING NEW BUILDING STARTED
GETTING THE ECONOMY.
RECOVERED.
BY.
BY HAVING THIS ABILITY WE WERE
ABLE TO STEP IN.
WITH THE STATE BRING IN STATE
CONTRACTORS.
RAPIDLY UP PUT IN PLACE UP A
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
DEBRIS CONTRACTING CONTRACT
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
UP THE DEBRIS REMOVAL.
WE HAD AYE AYE SIMILAR ISSUES
IN IN MONTECITO AT THE MUD FLOW
IN IN A VENTURA COUNTY.
THIS ISN'T SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN EVERY DAY THIS
IS SOMETHING WHERE WE HAVE TO
DIP INTO THIS.
THIS EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S PART OF THAT.
THAT.
SPECIALIZE FIND.
AND DIE IN ITS ONLY USED WHEN
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
WHAT THIS DOES IS IT JUST
CLARIFIES IS CLARIFIES THAT THAT
THE ALLOCATIONS FROM THE ACCOUNT?
ARE FOR ACTIVITIES THAT COMMENCE
WITHIN A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS
OF A PROCLAMATION RATHER THAN
WHAT IT IS NOW THAT OCCUR AFTER
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS OF THE
PROCLAMATION SO. EVEN THOUGH THE
GOVERNOR PROCLAIMED IN
CALIFORNIA ALL OF THESE EVENTS.
YOU KNOW.
.
WE NEED WE WE HAD ALREADY
COMMITTED SO MUCH TO THE NORTH.
THAT WHEN WE HAD MONO SETO AND
AND UP IN TARA.
.
YOU KNOW BE ABLE TO GET INTO
THIS ACCOUNT AND AND UTILIZE IT
BEFORE THAT HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
WAS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AFTER
THE GOVERNOR PROCLAIM. STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND OUT IN SANTA
BARBARA AND VENTURA COUNTIES.
SO THIS IS REALLY THIS IS
REALLY A TRADE CRAFT ISSUE IT'S
VERY NECESSARY FOR US TO BE WILL
BE ABLE TO HAVE THE GREATEST
FLEXIBILITY IN THE PIT IT
ACCORDINGLY. OUGHT TO MANAGE
THESE THESE VERY COMPLEX AND AND
THAT CATASTROPHIC EVENTS.
THANK YOU PART FINANCE. AND FOR
THE THE PURPOSE OF THE DISASTER
RESPONSE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT OF THE TRIO AS WE LIKE
TO CALL IT.
IS TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
ASSISTANCE TO STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCALS IN THE ABOUT AMERICA OF A
DISASTER. SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
LEGISLATION OR ALLEGED AND SORRY
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
IS.
DESIRED IF FOR THIS ONE I THINK
WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO CONTINUE
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE ONLY
OBAMA KIND OF LANGUAGE.
COULD BE.
THANK YOU AWARE.
SO WE DIDN'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS
WITH REMOVING THE SUNSET ON THIS
LANGUAGE.
AND WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
THAT VALUE OF PROVIDING IN SOME
CASES IT SOME MORE FLEXIBILITY
TO THE ADMINISTRATION WHEN
NECESSARY WHEN THESE ACTIVITIES.
TAKE A LITTLE BIT LONGER THAN
ANTICIPATED ON HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
SWITCHING.
THE LANGUAGE AS IS RECOMMENDED
HER AS HIS PROPOSED FROM
OCCURRED TO COMMENCE.
AND THE REASON WHY WERE ABOVE
THE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT IS
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
THIS THAT'S REPLACE THE
TRADITIONAL BUDGET PROCESS.
AND THAT THESE ACTIVITIES DON'T
EXTEND FOR YOUR REALLY EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE IF IT'S
JUST.
COMMENCE THEN PUT BEN THEY
COULD POTENTIALLY I USE THESE
FUNDS WHICH DON'T GO THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL BUDGET PROCESS.
FOR FOR WHO KNOWS HOW LONG.
SO I THINK OUR RECOMMENDED
APPROACH IS INSTEAD TO STICK
WITH THE.
COMMAND OR STICK WITH THE.
OCCUR WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAY PERIOD BUT ALLOW FOR
AN EXTENSION UPON AN ADDITIONAL
NOTIFICATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
SO THAT WAY THEY COULD GET
ADDITIONAL TIME THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE KEPT
INFORMED IF IT'S ADDITIONAL TIME
IS NECESSARY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
ANY COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S ROOM TO
WORK SOMETHING OUT HERE YEAH FOR
BETTER FOR WORSE LEGISLATURE
WANTS TO BE INVOLVED WELL I MEAN
LOOK WE KEEP TRACK OF IT SO IF
THERE'S A WAY. TO COME UP WITH
WITH A STRUCTURE SO THAT. WE CAN
DO OUR OVERSIGHT KEEP TRACK OF
WHERE THESE EXPENSES ARE I THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE A RELUCTANCE
TO HAVE.
TO ME IT'S OPEN ENDED. WITHOUT
THE ABILITY TO TO FOLLOW OUR
PROCESS YEAH WE DON'T LIKE
THERE'S YOU ALWAYS HAVE ROOM SO
WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THEM
OKAY.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT WE ARE GOING
TO HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
I MOVED ITEM NUMBER ISSUE NUMBER
TWELVE WHICH IS THE HOMELESS
YOUTH AND EXPLOITATION PROGRAM.
SO OF THIS PROGRAM.
IS THE HOME OF HIS PROGRAM
WHICH IS.
BEEN FUNDED SINCE.
THE MID NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
.
PER THE WELFARE INSTITUTION
CODE.
AND UP. THERE'S REALLY FOUR
CORE COUNTIES.
.
PER THE STATURE IT.
SANTA CLARA LOS ANGELES SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN DIEGO.
THESE PROJECTS THE PROJECTS IN
THESE CORE COUNTIES ARE
COMPETITIVELY SELECTED.
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AGO AND
INCLUDE.
AYE AYE NUMBER OF OF DIFFERENT
ADVANCE THE BILL WILSON CENTER
IN SANTA CLARA CHILDRENS
HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES THE LACKEY
ST YOU SAID IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
SAN DIEGO YOU SERVICES.
EDITION TO.
THREE THREE OF THESE FOUR ARE
PROJECTS RECENTLY COMPETITIVELY
SELECTED TO RECEIVE FUNDING
UNDER BY A NEW TEN MILLION
DOLLAR HOME ISSUED AN EMERGENCY
SERVICE HOUSING PROGRAM.
AND.
THIS PROPOSAL PROPOSES A
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH. A
COMPETITIVE REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS.
WITHIN THE FOUR CORE COUNTIES.
TO FIND NEW PROJECTS
THE HIGHEST SCORE PROPOSAL EACH
COUNTY WOULD BE FUNDED AT A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR
LEVEL. FOR EIGHTEEN MONTH GRANT
TOWARD PERFORMANCE PERIOD. OF
PICKING UP NEW PROJECTS WOULD
INCREASE THE SERVICES WITHIN
THESE RESPECTIVE OUT COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU PART FINANCE SO KNOW
THAT THIS PROPOSAL AND THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS
OPPOSE ALL IN THE NEXT ISSUE ARE
BOTH PART OF THE BROADER
HOMELESSNESS PACKAGE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PUT FOR IN THE.
IN THE MAY REVISION IN BOTH OF
THESE ARE JUST ONE TIME.
AUGMENTATIONS.
THANK YOU AWARE.
I SOMEONE WE DONE OUR INITIAL
ANALYSIS WE NOTED THERE IS A
LACK OF CERTAINTY ABOUT HOW
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE PROPOSED TO
BE SPENT.
SENSE THEN THE RECEIPTS
MITCHELL INFORMATION AS WAS
OUTLINES BY THE DIRECTOR.
REALLY.
THE LEGISLATURE PUTTING ONE
WITH US WHETHER THAT IS THE
PRIORITY IN TERMS OF THESE FUNDS
ON TO GO TO THIS THIS FOR
SPECIFIC COUNTIES ARE WHETHER
THEY PREFER A DIFFERENT APPROACH
CERTAINLY IS PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS.
ALSO JUST WANTED TO KNOW BOTH
WITH THIS AND I'M THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSAL ON THAT THAT THESE
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES ARE ALSO
FUNDED FREQUENTLY FROM FEDERAL
FUNDS THE STATE HAS.
ACCESS TO THOSE FUNDS THAT
DEPARTMENT.
DOES HAVE A SIGNIFICANT OF
DISCRETION ALLOCATING THOSE
FUNDS AYE SO ONE OF THE THINGS
TO CONSIDER SURE OF THE LARGER
CONTEXT.
THIS IS IT JUST ABLE TO BE
FUNDED BY THE GENERAL FUND THERE
ARE THOSE OTHER RESOURCES I'M SO
AS YOU HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
YOUR FOR YOUR. PREFERRED FUNDING
LEVEL FOR THESE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES.
CERTAINLY WORTH RECOGNIZING
THAT THEIR SUPPORT ALL FUNDS
THAT MIGHT BE AVAILABLE.
THANK YOU KNOWS THE PUBLIC.
THEY.
I CAN THERE IS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOU
THREE REPRESENT A RUNAWAY AND
HOMELESS YOUTH PROVIDERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. I'M WELL I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE PERSON
THAT I THINK THE PARTNER
FINANCES ACTUALLY INCREASE THE
PROPOSAL FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM AND I WOULD NOTE IT IS
ONLY ONE MILLION AND IF IT IS
ONLY ONE TIME. SO THE AMOUNT
IMPACT THIS IS GOING TO HAVE A
LONG TERM IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING
YOU HOMELESSNESS. AND I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE MORE AND ADDITIONAL
FUNDING PUT INTO THE PROGRAM AND
HAVE EXPANDED KINDA LIKE LAST
YEAR'S PROPOSAL WHERE IT WENT
OUT. TO ADDITIONAL I'M SUPPORTS
AND SERVICES TO INCLUDE HOUSING
AND SERVICES. I'M AND THIRTY.
BOARD.
THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE STATE
AND I KNOW THAT WOULD CUT IS
LIMITED AMOUNT BUT I THINK WE
SHOULD REALLY BE ADDRESSING THIS
WE HAVE FIFTEEN THOUSAND IVE
HUNDRED. UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS STATE
AND THAT'S ABOUT TWELVE PERCENT
OF THE ENTIRE HOMELESS YOUTH
POPULATION AND MOST YOUTH
EXPERIENCING.
OUR MOST OF THE CHRONIC ADULTS
HAVE EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS
WHEN THEY WERE YOU BETWEEN THE
AGES OF EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
AYE WE REALLY THINK THAT THIS
CAN REALLY ADDRESSED THE ISSUE
IN THE LONG RUN AND SO WE'RE
JUST OF THOSE COMING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE FROM THE PUBLIC.
SINGLE BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
SO I THINK THIS ALSO TAILORS AND
THERE'S THERE'S A PROPOSAL ALSO
MOVING THROUGH FOR AN OFFICE OF
HOMELESS YOUTH WITH HOPEFULLY A
LOT MORE.
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THIS IS A
MUCH BIGGER PROBLEM AND WE SEEM
TO BE LIMPING AROUND THE EDGES
SO I'M HOPING THE ADMINISTRATION
AS WELL WELL.
HELP US WITH SOMETHING MUCH
LARGER AND APPROPRIATE FOR
DEALING WITH WITH THIS
POPULATION.
SO WE ARE GOING TO HOLD ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE OPEN AS WELL TAKE
IT UNDER ADVISEMENT AND WILL
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHELTERS IN
SERVICES AND CARRY OUT.
THIS IS SUB ARE A REQUEST FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IT'S UP CAL
YES ADMINISTERS. DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM PROVIDE SHELTER
AND SUPPORTERS SERVICES TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS AND
THEIR CHILDREN. OF THE PROGRAM
HAS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO SUB
RECIPIENTS AND FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED EQUALLY AMONG THOSE.
SEVERI CYPRIAN'S.
WHICH IS REALLY WHAT WE GET IS
A RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ADVISORY
COUNCIL THAT WE PUT IN PLACE.
AND DIES VERY ACTIVE.
GROUP.
GRANT SUB AWARDS ARE WORDED NOT
COMPETITIVELY.
PER.
I STATURE IT.
WHICH WHICH CAN PROHIBITS NEW
PROGRAMS FROM HAVING ACCESS TO
STATE FUNDS.
SO CALLOUS VALUES.
INCREASE IN IN FUNDS IN FISCAL
YEAR ELEVEN AND TWELVE. AYE TO
OPEN A COMPETITIVE PROCESS AND
ADDED FOUR ADDITIONAL SUB
RECIPIENTS TO THE PROGRAM. I
NOTICED NO NO SHELTERS HAVE BEEN
ADDED SINCE THEN.
OF THE NEW.
TEN MILLION EIGHTY PERCENT.
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO THE
EXISTING PROGRAM SUB RECIPIENTS
AND TWENTY PERCENT.
WILL BE ALLOCATED BY COMPETITIVE
FUNDING FOR UP TO TEN ADDITIONAL
SUB RECIPIENTS.
SO EIGHTY PERCENT.
TO THE EXISTING SUB RECIPIENTS
THAT'S ROUGHLY A MILLION.
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO LONG TERM SHELTER
PROGRAMS WITH EXPERTISE ARE
PROVIDING OF THIS CRITICAL
SERVICE I WOULD ALLOW THESE
PROGRAMS TO EXPAND ONLY.
THE SHELTER COMPONENT OF THEIR
PROGRAM HOTEL VOUCHERS
ADDITIONAL BADS ADDITIONAL READ
THE FACILITIES OR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND WOOD AUGMENT EXISTING
PROGRAM.
WITH TWELVE MIGHT GRAB GRANT
SUB AWARD PERFORMANCE PERIOD.
I'M OF THE TWENTY PERCENT.
TO NEW SUB GRANTEES ROUGHLY TWO
MILLION IT WOULD OPEN UP.
IT WOULD BE OPEN FUNDING UP TO
TEN ADDITIONAL AGENCIES ARE WITH
EITHER.
THAT WILL EITHER PROVIDE OR
WANT TO PROVIDE SHELTER TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE VICTIMS AND
THEIR CHILDREN.
WILL PROVIDE EIGHTEEN MONTHS
GRANT SOMEWHERE PERFORMANCE
PERIOD TO ALLOW FOR TIME TO
START UP THE PRO NEW PROGRAM.
AND THE PROGRAM WOULD BE LIMITED.
TO HOUSING BASED ON SERVICES
SAME AS I MENTIONED BEFORE HOTEL
VOUCHERS BADS.
RENTAL FACILITIES ARE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU CARD FINANCE LA.
THE SAME COMMENTED ON THE
PREVIOUS PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU ANY MEMBER THE PUBLIC.
SINGER QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THAT
ITEM OPEN AS WELL.
TAKE IT UNDER ADVISEMENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL NOW MOVE TO ISSUE NUMBER
FOURTEEN THAT. BRING UP CDC ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE
HAVE A GREAT DAY THANK YOU.
WE MADE AS MUCH PROGRESS AS WE
COULD.
CAN.
ISSUE NUMBER FOURTEEN.
.
MAYBE VISION ADULT AND JUVENILE
POPULATION ADJUSTMENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR WHINING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
JASON LOPEZ CDC ARE.
SHOULD I GIVE IT JUST A MINUTE
TO QUIET DOWN A LITTLE BETTER WE
OKAY TO.
WELL.
WE'VE GOT SHIFTS OF FOLKS COMING
IN.
THOSE ARE MY FOLKS TO THE LATEST
WAVE OF OKAY.
I THINK THEIR THE DOORS CLOSING
SO THANK YOU.
OKAY.
AS YOU MENTIONED FIRST ISSUE UP
FOR CDC R. INVOLVES OUR
POPULATION PROJECTIONS SO AS YOU
ARE ALL AWARE BY NOW.
TWICE YEARLY THE DEPARTMENT'S
OFFICE OF RESEARCH IS ASKED TO
PROJECT WHAT OUR OFFENDER
POPULATIONS ARE GOING TO BE.
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
.
TYPICALLY THIS WILL ACCOMPANY
THAT JAN TEN RELEASE OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND THEN YOU'LL
SEE IT AGAIN HERE IN THE MAY
REVISE.
WITH OUR SPRING PROJECTIONS SO
WITH ME TODAY IS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
JULIE BASCO.
OF THE DEPARTMENT'S OFFICE OF
RESEARCH SHE'S GONNA WALK YOU
THROUGH SOME OF THE METHODOLOGY
THAT GOES INTO DEVELOPING THE
NUMBERS THAT THEY PRODUCE AND
THEN WE'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR.
AS JASON INDICATED OUR.
OFFICE PREPARES THE POPULATION
PROJECTIONS TWICE A YEAR AND OUR
CURRENT VERSION IS THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SPRING POPULATION
PROJECTION REPORT AND THAT
RELEASED ALONGSIDE THE MAY
REVISE.
THIS CAR AROUND WE DID PROVIDE A
HANDOUT SHEET THAT WILL COVER
MANY OF THE NUMBERS THAT I'M
GOING TO GO THROUGH THIS MORNING.
SO FIRST OF WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW IT ALL INSTITUTION
POPULATION WAS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE THOUSAND. TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY OFFENDERS ON JUNE
THIRTY TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
OUR PROJECTION FOR JUNE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN IS A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY TWO OFFENDERS THIS IS A
ONE YEAR DECREASE HAVE NEARLY
THREE THOUSAND OFFENDERS OR TWO
POINT ONE PERCENT.
OUR REPORT PROJECTS ANNUAL
INSTITUTION POPULATION GROWTH
DECLINING IN THE NEXT TWO BUDGET
CYCLES AND THIS IS LARGELY DUE
TO PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN'S
ENHANCE CREDIT EARNING STRUCTURE.
IN THESE ENHANCEMENTS BEGAN
AFFECTING THE OFFENDER
POPULATION LAST JUNE SO NOT
QUITE A YEAR AGO.
SO ADDITIONALLY OUR COURT
COMMITMENTS ARE CURRENT AT A
LOWER NUMBER THAN WE PROJECTED
AND OUR FALL REPORT. AND THAT'S
DRIVING THE INSTITUTION
POPULATION LOWER THAN WE
PROJECTED THAT.
SO BY JUNE THIRTY TWENTY
NINETEEN THE INSTITUTION
POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO BE
ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED OFFENDERS
LOWER THAN EXPECTED IN THE FALL.
HIM BY JUNE TWENTY TWENTY IT
SHOULD BE ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED
OFFENDERS LOWER.
SO WHERE DOES THAT PUT THE STATE
IN TWO YEARS JUNE TWENTY TWENTY.
WITH AN ADULT INSTITUTION
POPULATION PROJECTED AT A
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN OFFENDERS.
AND THAT WOULD RESULT THAT
PROJECTION WILL RESULT IN A TWO
YEAR DECREASE OF FOUR THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FOUR
OFFENDERS.
MOVING ON TO PEARL PROJECTIONS
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROJECTIONS
ARE ALSO LOWERED THEM WE
PRODUCED IN OUR FALL REPORT.
THE LOWER PROJECTED INSTITUTION
POPULATION IS PROJECTED TO
RESOLVE IN LOWER RELEASES TO
PEARL AND THERE BY A LOWER
PAROLE POPULATION.
BY JUNE THIRTY TWENTY NINETEEN
THE PAROLE POPULATION IS
PROJECTED TO BE ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED PAROLEES LOWER THAN WE
ANTICIPATED IN THE FALL. AND BY
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED PAROLEES LOWER.
THE PEARL POPULATION WAS FORTY
FIVE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ONE ON JUNE THIRTY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
OUR PROJECTION FOR JUNE THIRTY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE.
THIS IS A ONE YEAR INCREASE OF
FIVE PERCENT.
AND FROM HERE THE PAROLE
PROJECTIONS INCREASE FURTHER IN
THE NEXT FEW BUDGET CYCLES.
JUNE TWENTY TWENTIES PEARL
POPULATION PROJECTS AT FORTY
NINE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY NINE. AND THAT'S A TWO
YEAR INCREASE OF TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT PAROLEES.
FINALLY OUR YOUTH POPULATION.
JUNE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO AVERAGE
DAILY POPULATION WAS SIX HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR YOUTH.
FOR JUNE TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR
PROJECTION DECREASES SLIGHTLY TO
A SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
AVERAGE DAILY POPULATION.
THEN AGAIN DRIVEN BY PROPOSITION
FIFTY SEVEN JUVENILE COURT
PROVISIONS WE PROJECT AN
INCREASED AVERAGE DAILY
POPULATION OF SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN YOU. FOR JUNE OF
TWENTY NINETEEN.
I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THROUGH.
BUT ANY COMMENTS FROM OF FINANCE
BELIAU.
OKAY ANY MEMBER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS.
YOU'RE PROJECTING A USE INCREASE
POPULATION YES WE ARE. AND
THAT'S BASED ON.
SO PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN HAD
THE PROVISION TO ALLOW USED TO
GO BACK TO A JUVENILE COURT FOR
RECENT INSANE. AND THAT DID NOT
OCCUR AS EARLY AS WE HAD
ANTICIPATED THERE WAS SOME
ISSUES WITH FORMER SUPREME
PRODUCED BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND SO OUR INITIAL EXPECTATION
THAT WE WOULD SEE. AN INCREASE
AT OUR DJJ FACILITIES BECAUSE OF
YOUTH BEING REFERRED THROUGH THE
JUVENILE COURT PROCESS DID NOT
OCCUR AS EARLY AS WE EXPECTED SO
THIS INCREASE NOW IS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THOSE CASES
CLEARING OUT OF THE COUNTY LEVEL.
ALRIGHT FINE.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS ANYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
HOW MANY. PHONE.
COMMENTS ALRIGHT FINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
WITH ISSUE NUMBER FIFTEEN.
HEPATITIS C..
TREATMENT FUNDING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR PUTTING
MY NAME IS DOING READER I AM
WITH A CALIFORNIA CHRIS ON
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND.
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL. FOR ROUGHLY
A HUNDRED SIX MILLION OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS.
TO EXPAND TREATMENT OF HCV TO
THE INMATE POPULATION.
THERE.
IS THE PREVALENCE RATE OF ABOUT
SIXTEEN PERCENT.
WITHIN THE INSTITUTION
POPULATION WHICH IS MUCH GREATER
THAN THAT OUT IN THE PUBLIC.
.
WE ALSO.
ARE LOOKING TO EXPAND THIS WITH.
OTHER CALIFORNIA AGENCIES.
NOT NOT JUST WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT BUT DO SAGE AND.
MEDICARE I'LL HAVE.
ALSO INCREASED INITIATIVES.
THIS IS LARGELY DRIVEN BY THE
CDC GUIDELINES THAT HAVE%
EXPANDED TREATMENT ON THE
ORIGINAL GUIDELINES.
.
WERE TO TREAT STAGE THREE AND
FOR PATIENTS EXCLUSIVELY AND
THAT TREATMENT HAS BEEN
BROADENED TO TREAT ALL PATIENTS
REGARDLESS OF STAGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS THEM
COULD YOU WRITE.
I'M HERE TO TAKE QUESTIONS OKAY.
ANY ANY OTHER CALM ANY LA UP OF.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
SINCE THE END OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE JUST WANTED TO
UNDERSCORE THAT THE.
I'VE STATEWIDE EFFORTS HIT WITH
MEDI CAL INDIA SAGE TO.
PROVIDE TREATMENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND FOR CHRONIC
HEPATITIS C. VIRUS ACROSS ALL
STAGES OF THE DISEASE
PROGRESSION.
OKAY NO COMMENTS ANYWAY ANY.
ANY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
OKAY A ANY MEMBER COMMENTS.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT ITEM. NO THANK YOU.
I ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN
CONTRABAND INTERDICTION PROGRAM.
YEAH.
ISSUE NUMBER SIXTEEN.
YES.
OKAY I WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS NINE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET
YEAR ANY POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY
TOOK EMPLOYMENT A TWO YEAR
CONTRABAND INTERDICTION PILOT
PROGRAM AND TO EXPAND OUR
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
AT THE SUBSIDIES TREATMENT
FACILITY LOCATED IN CORCORAN.
THE CURRENT MAP PILOT PROGRAM IS
OPERATING AT OUR CIW IN CIM
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AREA.
THIS PROPOSAL INCLUDES TO YOU
CAN LIMON A TWO YEAR LIMIT TERM
STAFFING FOR APPROXIMATELY FORTY
BECAUSE CITY STAFF. TO
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF AND SIX
HEALTH CARE STAFF.
I'M JOINED THIS MORNING BY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CONNIE GIPSON OF
OUR DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS AND ABBAS CATHERINE
TO BROCK WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF OUR STATEWIDE MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAM. THEY'RE GONNA
PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE DETAIL
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL THAT WE BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK. GOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE DRUG USE OF CELL PHONES
WITHIN OUR PRISONS CONTINUE TO
BE OF SIGNIFICANT CONCERN FOR
THE DEPARTMENT. IF CALENDAR YEAR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE DISCOVERED
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND
CELLPHONES. OVER FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY SIX POUNDS OF TOBACCO.
OVER SIXTEEN THOUSAND GRAMS
METHAMPHETAMINE OVER TEN
THOUSAND GRAMS OF HEROIN AND
OVER THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND GRAMS
OF MARIJUANA. AND I TELL YOU WE
DIDN'T GET IT ALL BECAUSE WE
KNOW IN MAYES TODAY ARE STILL
USING CELLPHONES TO CONDUCT
CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES. AS WELL AS
IN MAYES CONTINUE TO OVERDOSE
AND DIE BAHAI ILLEGAL DRUGS
WITHIN OUR PRESENTS. AND
CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY ELEVEN WE
HAD NINE OVERDOSE DEATH.
WITH FIVE HUNDRED AND OVER FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEDICAL
CONTACTS
DUE TO SUSPECTED OVERDOSES.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD
THIRTY EIGHT DEATHS DUE TO
OVERDOSE. WITH SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MEDICAL CONTACTS DUE TO A
LOT SUSPECTED OVERDOSES.
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND IN A FOR
DOING THE NUMBER CONTINUES TO
GROW WE'RE LOOKING AT TEN
SUSPECTED OVERDOSE DEATHS WOULD
NUMEROUS MEDICAL ENCOUNTERS THAT
HAVE SAVED LIVES.
THIS PROPOSAL OF CONTRABAND
INTERDICTION PROGRAM UTILIZATION
AT CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE FACILITY AT
COURT GRANT. AIMS TO INTERDICT
THE DRUGS COME INTO OUR PRESENCE
THE CONTRABAND COMING IN BY
UTILIZING A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
OPERATION IN THE FRONT ENTRANCE
AREAS. UTILIZING.
MILLIMETER WAVE BODY SCANNERS
BAGGAGE SCANNERS SO THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL WHO ENTERS OUR
PRESENT FOR ANY LEGITIMATE
REASON. WILL BE SNUBBED WILL BE
SCREENED. ADDITIONALLY THE
EXPANSION OF SIX CAME NINETEEN
SO SUBSTANCE THAT HAVE WELL
ALLOW FOR US TO DO VEHICLE
SEARCHES. TO SEARCH OUR HEARTS
PEOPLE SALLY POURS WILL WE KNOW
CONTRABAND IS BEING SMUGGLED
THROUGH WITH CIVILIANS.
PUT PACKAGES UNDERNEATH THE
CARRIAGE OF VEHICLES HOPING TO
BE DRIVEN INTO OUR SECURE
PERIMETER.
I ASK FOR THIS COMMITTEE
SUPPORT FOR THIS PROPOSAL AND
I'LL DEFER TO MY PARTNER HERE.
OKAY GOOD MORNING CATHERINE TO
BROCK.
STATEWIDE MENTAL HEALTH.
DIRECTOR OF THE.
AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THE
DRUG INTERDICTION STRATEGY
DESCRIBE I MISS GIPSON IS THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A COMPANION
MATT PROGRAMS MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT. I AS YOU KNOW WE
IMPLEMENTED A PILOT MATH PROGRA
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AT CIM AND CIW.
AYE WE'RE NOW IN THE THIRD A
YEAR OF THAT THREE YEAR PILOT
WE'VE SUBMITTED TO OUR ANNUAL
REPORTS TO THIS BODY.
THIS PILOT SEEKS TO EMULATE.
THE APPROACH IN THE CURRENT CA
MNC AT W.. UP PILOTS YEAH AND
REALIZING MORE HEAVILY ON OUR
MEDICAL AND NURSING COUNTERPARTS
TO HELP DELIVER THE CARE. UP THE
REASON FOR THIS SHIFT IS BECAUSE
IT IS MORE COST EFFICIENT AND IT
LEVERAGES STAFF ALREADY ON SITE.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE MATT
PROGRAM IS MOST EFFECTIVE WHEN
OPERATED THROUGH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A COMPLETE
CARE MODEL.
OP ED WHICH REQUIRES.
PATIENT CARE TO BE VIEWED IN
AND THE PATIENTS THEMSELVES TO
BE YOU VIEWED AS A WHOLE PERSON.
SO IT INTEGRATES INTER
DISCIPLINARY DISCUSSIONS TO
IMPROVE.
.
MORE INDIVIDUALIZED TREATMENT
PLANS AND IMPROVE OVERALL
OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS.
OF ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
LENNY CHAMADO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OUT WE'D LIKE TO KNOW
THAT THIS PROPOSALS CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL PRISON STANDARDS
SCREENING EVERYONE UPON ENTRY.
AND ADDITIONALLY THE COSTS IN
THIS ARE HIGHER THAN THE PROGRAM
THAT WAS IMPLEMENTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
BECAUSE IT IS A MUCH MORE
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM. I WAS
SCREENING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN.
AND IT AIMS TO BRING THEM
INTERDICT DRUGS AT ALL AVENUES
AND CELLPHONE.
I AM ADDITIONALLY.
CDC OUR PLANS CHIU OUR WORK WITH
A CONTRACTOR WANTS THEIR CHOSEN
TO DETERMINE WHAT DATA IS
AVAILABLE.
AND DISCUSS WHAT THEY MIGHT
NEED TO DO AN EFFECTIVE
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY AYE AYES MISTY
BROCK SAID CIM IN CIW CURRENTLY
HAVE A MAP PROGRAM SO. THIS
PROGRAM WITH A COMBINATION OF
MATT AND THE INTRODUCTION CAN BE
COMPARED TO THAT TO SEE HOW
EFFECTIVE IT IS. AND.
CCR CAN USE THAT DATA OF WHERE
THE DRUGS ARE FOUND AND HOW MUCH
SHOULD I SYSTEM EVALUATION.
WE HAVE THE COMES FROM.
HELLO.
CAITLYN O'NEILL AT THE LA AUTO
WE RECOGNIZE THAT CONTRABAND IN
PRISON IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM AND
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS TAKEN A PILOT
APPROACH WITH AN EVALUATION
COMPONENT.
HOWEVER WE DO RECOMMEND
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL FOR TWO
REASONS.
FIRST IT APPEARS RELATIVELY
COSTLY.
STATE LAW AND JUST TO ILLUSTRATE
THAT WE ESTIMATE THAT STATEWIDE
EXPANSION OF THIS PROGRAM WOULD
COST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND REQUIRE
HUNDREDS OF ADDITIONAL
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS TO OPERATE.
IT'S ALSO MORE THAN TEN TIMES AS
EXPENSIVE ON A PER PERSON BASIS
THAN THE EARLIER PILOT THAT I
MISUSED ISHIMOTO REFERENCED.
DOT AND NOT PILOT WAS FOUND TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN CERTAIN CASES.
SECOND THE PROGRAM DOESN'T
APPEAR TO BE DESIGNED TO ALLOW
FOR MEANINGFUL VALUATION EVEN IF
RESEARCHERS ARE BROUGHT IN.
WHEAT TO TO LOOK AT IT WE THINK
THAT.
IT WOULD BE CHALLENGING FOR
THEM TO COME UP WITH A
MEANINGFUL EVALUATION. BASED ON
THIS IS BECAUSE THE OF THAT
PROGRAM DOESN'T INCLUDE RANDOM
DRUG TESTING OF INMATES WHICH
WAS A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
EARLIER EVALUATION.
IT WOULD ONLY TEST WHETHER THE
ENTIRE PACKAGE OF INTERVENTIONS
WAS EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING IN
MADE DRUG USE AND OTHER THINGS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
TRYING TO FAX SUCH AS VIOLENCE.
THE.
THE ADMINISTRATION INDICATES
THAT THEY BELIEVE THAT TRACKING
THE NUMBER OF DRUG FINES.
MADE THE OF VARIOUS
INTERVENTIONS WOULD ALLOW IT TO
CONCLUDE WHICH INTERVENTIONIST
FIVE MOST EFFECTIVE HOWEVER WE
STILL HAVE CONCERN. CONCERNS
THERE FROM EVALUATION
PERSPECTIVE THAT IF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS. REDUCE INMATE
DRUG USE REDUCE VIOLENCE EXCITER
WE SHOULD BE TRACKING THOSE
METRICS NOT SIMPLY HOW MANY
DRUGS WERE FINDING. FOR EXAMPLE
IT COULD BE THAT.
IN RESPONSE TO THE INCREASE
INTERDICTION EFFORTS THE
SMUGGLERS SIMPLY STEPPED UP
THERE TRAFFICKING EFFORTS
SENDING MORE DRUGS THROUGH.
THE ADMINISTRATION CATCHES MORE
THINKING THAT IT'S EFFECTIVE BUT
THE SAME AMOUNT ULTIMATELY GETS
THROUGH. THAT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE.
.
WE ALSO NOTE THAT THE PROGRAM
ONLY INCLUDES ONE INSTITUTION SO
WOULD BE HARD TO KNOW. WHETHER
OR NOT IT WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL IF
IMPLEMENTED ELSEWHERE.
FINALLY. WEKNOW THAT IFTHE
LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED IN
PURSUING A PILOT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND THAT IT. DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH THE
RESEARCHER TO DIVINE TO DESIGN A
PILOT THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR MORE
MEANINGFUL EVALUATION AND. COME
BACK POTENTIALLY IN JANUARY WITH
ANOTHER PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF I COULD
RESPOND TO THE LA DOES CONCERN
IN REGARDS TO AVAILABLE DATA
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
MAINTAINED AS RELATES TO
CONTRABAND INTERDICTION.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED A SUREPOINT
SITE BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN THAT MAINTAINS SEVERAL
AREAS OF DATA THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE THAT IN WORKING WITH
THE RESEARCHER WHO MAY BE
CONTRACTED. IDENTIFYING THAT
DATA SOURCE THAT WE ALREADY HAVE
AND THEY WORK WITH THEM TO
IDENTIFY ANY OTHER KEY ELEMENTS
THAT THEY BELIEVE WILL BE
BENEFICIAL. SO THAT THIS.
RESEARCH OF THIS PILOT COULD BE
THOROUGH AND COMPLETE. AND SO WE
DO HAVE DATA SHAREPOINT.
DATA THAT IS AVAILABLE FOR
RESEARCH AT TO EVALUATE.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
MEMBER COMMENTS.
OKAY FINE ALRIGHT WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
THATITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN
WOULD NOT IT ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS OVER TIME
BASED JUST.
BUDGET ADJUSTMENT.
OKAY WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST SIXTEEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS STARTING IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
TO ADJUST THE DEPARTMENT BASS
ADVERTISE AND FINDING.
THIS IS DESIGNED TO SET THAT
FUNDING LEVEL.
CONSISTENT WITH SO.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN THE LAST TIME THE
DEPARTMENTS OVER TIME FUNDING
WAS ADJUSTED.
.
SINCE THEN THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF.
SALARY INCREASES THAT HAVE BEEN
ACCOUNTED FOR ON THE EMPLOYEE
COM.
ANNUAL EXERCISE AND THAT
EXERCISE HAS NOT HISTORICALLY
ACCOUNTED FOR INCREASES.
TO OVERTIME RATES WHICH
OBVIOUSLY ACCOMPANIED SALARY
INCREASES THIS REQUEST IS JUST
TO ACCOUNT FOR THOSE INCREASES
THAT HAVE OCCURRED SINCE
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN I'M WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT GOING FORWARD.
WILL WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO ACCOUNT FOR THOSE
INCREASES ALONG WITH ANY SALARY
INCREASES THAT OCCUR THROUGH THE
EMPLOYEE COMPACTS ARE SIZE.
ANY COMMENT. FINANCE
BELIAU.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE TEXAS
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN.
HE TWO EXCUSE ME WHICH IS
TRAINING INITIATIVES.
OKAY.
.
WITH THIS PROPOSAL CDC OUR
REQUEST TWELVE POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND FIVE POSITIONS
TWENTY ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THE
NINETEEN POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING STARTING IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO ADD
TRAINING FOR THEIR APARTMENTS
PEACE OFFICER IN SUPERVISORY
POSITIONS.
THIS PROPOSAL INVOLVES
ADDITIONAL TRAINING FOR THOSE
WHO ATTEND OUR BASIC
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER ACADEMY OUR
OFFICE TRAINING FOR A BECAUSE
CITY STAFF ARE ANNUAL
SUPERVISORY AND MANAGERIAL
TRAININGS I COMMAND COLLEGE FOR
OUR CUSTODY LEADERS. AND A BASIC
AND SPECIALIZED INVESTIGATOR
TRAINING
FOR OUR SPECIAL AGENT AND OUR
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES UNIT
STAFF.
THE FIVE POSITIONS REQUESTED
WILL ALLOW THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE INVESTIGATIVE TRAINING UNIT
WITHIN OUR OFFICE OF INTERNAL
AFFAIRS.
THIS UNIT WILL BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR OVERSIGHT AND ADMINISTRATION
OF OUR STATEWIDE SPECIAL AGENT
AND I S. YOU STAFF TRAINING. I'M
JOINED THIS MORNING BY ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR STACY LOPEZ OF OUR
PEACE OFFICER SELECTION AND
EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT A SHE'S
GONNA TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PROPOSAL AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS DIRECTOR
LOOK THE STATE I'M CC LOPEZ I'M
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR WITH THE
PEACE OFFICER SELECTION AND
EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT.
DIRECTOR LOOK IS COVERED MANY
OF THE.
ASKED WITH OUR PROPOSAL I WANT
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
TRAINING THAT'S GOING TO BE
PROVIDED IN EACH OF THESE AREAS.
FIRST WE HAVE THE BUT EXTRA WEEK
FOR THE BASIC CRUX OFFICER
ACADEMY FOR OUR CADETS GOING OUT
INTO THE INSTITUTIONS. AND THE
TRAINING THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
ADDING IS IMPLICIT BIAS
EMPLOYEES WALDRON REHABILITATION
LEADERSHIP TEAM BUILDING AND
ALSO ADDING SOME ADDITIONAL
CADET ON SITE TRAINING VISITS. A
pDURING THOSE TWELVE WEEKS GIVES
CADETS AN OPPORTUNITY TO SEE A
PRISON.
THE INSIDE A PRISON BEFORE THEY
ACTUALLY GO OUT AND WORK AND ONE.
WITH REGARDS TO THE OFFICE
TRAINING WERE ADDING EIGHT OUT
WE LOOKED OUT EIGHT HOURS TO OUR
FORTY HOURS CUDGEL. AND AGAIN WE
WOULD HAVE BE THREADING SIMILAR
TOPICS SUCH AS WHAT I JUST
MENTIONED OF IMPLICIT BIAS
ETHICAL DECISION MAKING AND
TRUST. EMPLOYEES ROLE IN
REHABILITATION AND ALSO STRESS
RESILIENCY AND WELLNESS A
TRAINING FOR OUR STAFF IN THE
FIELD.
TAKING THAT.
TO THE SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
WE ARE REQUESTING TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL WEEK TO OUR.
MANAGEMENT TRAINING AND
CURRENTLY IT'S IT OUT EIGHTY
HOURS FOR ALL FIRST AND SECOND
LINE SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
AND WE'RE LOOKING TO.
OUT ANOTHER IN A WEEK.
ADDITIONAL WEEK TO THAT WITH
AGAIN SIMILAR TOPICS THAT WE
WOULD BE TRAINING THE CADETS
THE LINE STAFF AND THEN TAKING
IT TO THE SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS. IN ADDITION TO.
MORE LEADERSHIP AND MANAGERIAL
TRAINING FOR OUR SUPERVISORS AND
MANAGERS.
AS I MENTIONED ALL THE ABOVE
TOPICS WILL BE THREADED THROUGH
THE TRAINING SO WE'RE HITTING
ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES STARTING
WITH THE CADETS.
AND THEN MOVING FORWARD UP TO
THE SUPERVISORS AND MANAGERS
ANOTHER PIECE OF THIS AS IT WAS
MENTIONED ISTHE COMMAND COLLEGE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO.
CONTRACT WITH THE COMMISSION ON
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING AND THIS WOULD BE A
TRAINING THAT WOULD BE PROVIDED
TO OUR CORRECTIONAL CAPTAINS.
AND ABOVE AND IT'S A FOURTEEN TO
SIXTEEN MONTH PROGRAM NOT ALL AT
ONE TIME.
THE WHERE THEY GET TO GO TO
LEADERSHIP TRAINING AND INTERACT
WITH OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LEADERS WITHIN THE STATE.
AND LASTLY WE'RE ASKING.
AS PART OF OUR PROPOSAL TO OF
FUND US OF INVESTIGATOR TRAINING
FOR OUR INSTITUTION SERVICES
UNITS WHICH WOULD ENTAIL OUR
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ARE
SERGEANTS AND OUR LIEUTENANTS.
TO GO THROUGH BASIC INVESTIGATOR
TRAINING AND THEN SOME ADVANCED.
INVESTIGATOR TRAINING FOR OUR
SPECIAL AGENTS THAT WORK FOR
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND
CORRECTIONAL SAFETY.
THE IMPLEMENTATION FOR ALL OF
THIS WOULD NOT BEGIN JULY FIRST
WE'RE LOOKING AT AND FACES THE
ACADEMY PIECE WOULD START IN
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
IF THIS IS APPROVED. AND THE
FIELD TRAINING AND THE
SUPERVISORY TRAINING WOULD BEGIN
IN JANUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN M. NEXT FISCAL YEAR. AS
WELL AS THE INVESTIGATOR
TRAINING. I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
ANY COMMENTS FINANCE.
WENDY SHERMAN A DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
EXPANSION OF THE ACADEMY OFFICE
TRAINING AND ADVANCED MANAGEMENT
PROPOSAL ASSUMES A JANUARY TWO
THOUSAND NINE IMPLEMENTATION SO
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT.
A LITTLE OVER SIX MONTHS TO
DEVELOP ANY NEED TRAINING AS
NECESSARY BUT ALSO THEY HAVE
EXISTING TREE NEW TRAINING WHICH
COULD BE IMPLEMENTED.
I ADDITIONALLY CVC ARE RE
EVALUATES THEIR TRAINING
ANNUALLY TO DETERMINE IF ANY
TRAINING SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
AND NEW ONE SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED.
.
LA DON'T.
WE DON'T RAISE CONCERNS WITH THE
PROPOSAL TO EXPAND INVESTIGATOR
TRAINING. AND AND WE KNOWLEDGE
AT THE REMAINING TERM TRAINING
THAT'S PROPOSED COULD ADDRESS
REAL CHALLENGES FACED BY THE
DEPARTMENT.
HOWEVER WE'VE FOUND THAT THE
DEPARTMENT AND PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION WITH
WHICH TRICKS THAT FAST WEATHER.
DOT REMAINING PROPOSED TRAINING
WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL IN
ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES.
FOR EXAMPLE IT'S UNCLEAR WHAT
CURRICULAR TRAINING MATERIAL
WOULD BE USED WHETHER THE
PROPOSED TRAINING HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SUCCESSFULLY
ELSEWHERE AND WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS THAT IT
WOULD BE. SUCCESSFUL IN
ADDRESSING CHALLENGES HERE.
ROOM.
FURTHERMORE IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER.
SOME OF THESE ADDITIONAL
TRAININGS COULD BE OFFERED IN
LIEU OF EXISTING TRAININGS FOR
EXAMPLE. AND THEY DEPARTMENT
CURRENTLY OFFERS FORTY HOURS A
YEAR TO ALL STAFF AT PRISONS OF
TRAINING. PERHAPS SOME OF THESE
AND THESE PROPOSED A THE
PROPOSED EIGHT HOURS OF
ADDITIONAL ANNUAL TRAINING COULD
BE FOLDED INTO THAT EIGHTY HOURS
SO THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF A PIECE
OF INFORMATION THAT IF WERE
PROVIDED TO THE LEGISLATURE A
COULD. REVIEW THOSE EXISTING
TRAININGS AND ASSESS WHETHER
WANTED TO SUBSTITUTE THE NEW
ONES AND.
ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY FINE LOOK THANK YOU THANK
YOU THAT I DON'T TO WILL BE HELD
OPEN. OF THE CORRECTIONAL
COUNSELOR ó ONE. RACIAL
ADJUSTMENT.
OKAY WITH THIS PROPOSAL.
AND IN AN EFFORT TO ENHANCE THE
LEVEL OF REHABILITATION AND
PROGRAM ENROLLMENT ASSISTANCE
PROVIDED TO OUR OFFENDER
POPULATION.
CITY SEE OUR REQUEST THIRTEEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
EIGHTY NINE POINT TWO
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELOR ONE
POSITIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
CURRENTLY THIS CLASSIFICATION IS
ADJUSTED TWICE YEARLY AS PART OF
THE POPULATION PROCESS.
THAT RATIO IS CURRENTLY ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY OFFENDERS TO
EVERYONE COUNSELOR THIS PROPOSAL
INVOLVES CHANGING THAT RATIO TO.
ONE COUNSELOR FOR EVERY ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
OFFENDERS I'M JOINED BY JENNIFER
BRETT WHO IS OUR.
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITHIN
OUR DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS SHE'S GOING TO
EXPAND A LITTLE BIT ON THE
PROPOSAL AND THEN WE'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THE CURRENT
COUNSELOR TO OFFENDER RATIO OF A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO ONE DOES
NOT ALLOW FOR AN IN DEPTH ONE ON
ONE INTERACTION WITH THE INMATES
ON THEIR CASELOAD.
THE RATIOS REMAIN THE SAME FOR
DECADES DESPITE NUMEROUS CHANGES
IN AND WORKLOAD INCREASES IN
WORKLOAD OVER THE COURSE OF TIME.
CANCERS HAVE DIRECT INTERACTION
WITH THE INMATES ON THEIR
CASELOADS.
HOWEVER WITH THE CURRENT RATIO
WORKLOAD REQUIREMENTS THERE
SIMPLY ISN'T TIME TO SPEND WITH
THEM DEVISING THEIR INDIVIDUAL
STRATEGY FOR THE REHABILITATION
REENTRY.
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS WITH
REDUCED CASELOADS BY MAKING THE
ADJUSTMENT TO THE WAY WE'RE
BUDGETED ON THE RATIO. OF STAFF
TO A FENDER.
WOULD ALLOW THEM TO SPEND TIME
MATCHING INMATES TO THE VIABLE
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM SUITED
FOR THEM.
THIS WILL IMPROVE THE OVER
OVERALL WRAPAROUND APPROACH THE
DEPARTMENT IS TAKEN. WITH
INDIVIDUAL REHABILITATIVE NEEDS.
IT WILL ENABLE THE COUNSELORS TO
ADVOCATE AND SERVE MORE AS A
GUIDANCE COUNSELOR TYPE ROLE TO
THE INMATES.
HELPING THEM FROM THE TIME THAT
THEY COME IN. TO INCARCERATION
AND TELL THE TIME THAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT PAROLA RELEASE TO MAP
THEIR PLAN AND STRATEGY.
JUST AS AN EXAMPLE.
COUNSELORS IF THEY HAD LESS ON
THEIR CASELOAD COULD ASSIST IN
INMATE WHO INDICATES THEY'D LIKE
TO IMPROVE THEIR PARENTAL
RELATIONSHIP. BY POINTING THEM
TO EXISTING SELF HELP PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE THOSE SERVICES.
THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL
OVERALL BENEFIT THE DEPARTMENT
AND THE AND ME ENSURING
SUCCESSFUL REHABILITATION
REENTRY.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS IN FINANCE.
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT. TO PROVIDE MORE
COUNSELING TO THE INMATES THERE
THE ONE THE KEY CC ONES ARE THE
ONES WHO KNOW THE INMATES THE
BASS AND THEN IT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO ENGAGE MORE WITH THE INMATES
TO DETERMINE WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE. AND REALLY PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE WITH THAT.
LEóN.
WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THIS
PROPOSAL BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT
DIDN'T DEMONSTRATE THE NEED TO
REDUCE COUNSELOR CASELOADS.
IT'S ARGUED THAT WORKLOAD FOR
COUNSELORS HAD GONE UP BY HASN'T
MADE IT MADE IT CLEAR WHAT
PROBLEM THAT HAS CREATED.
I.
FURTHERMORE IT'S UNCLEAR Y.
COUNSELORS NEED MORE TIME TO
IDENTIFY REHABILITATION PROGRAMS
FOR INMATES IN OTHER WORDS WHAT
WHAT IS THE REASON THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY NOT SUFFICIENTLY ABLE
TO DO THIS.
FURTHERMORE IT'S UNCLEAR Y.
COUNSELORS NEED TO SPEND MORE
TIME HELPING INMATES PLANNED FOR
RELEASE WHEN CDC ARE ALREADY HAD
STAFF WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALSO NOT
PROVIDED EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST
THAT MORE ONE ON ONE TIME IS
NEEDED BETWEEN COUNCILLORS AND
INMATES FOR EXAMPLE THEY HAVE
INDICATED THAT. INMATES ARE
CURRENTLY BEING TURNED AWAY FROM
REQUESTING TO MEET WITH
COUNSELORS DUE TO LACK OF
CANCERS AVAILABILITY.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM. THE
AUDIENCE.
ANY MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESPOND TO THE
ISSUE OF THE NEED.
YES COUNSELORS AS I INDICATED
WITH OUR WORKLOAD. IT'S BECOME
MORE OF A ROLE OF ASSIGNING
INMATES TO THAT JOB ASSIGNMENTS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
HOUSING THEM IN FOLLOWING THE
BASIC POLICIES AND PROCEDURES OF
THEIR JOB.
AND IT IS IT'S MOVED FROM
PREVIOUSLY THEY WOULD SPEND A
LOT OF TIME AS COUNSELORS
GUIDING THE INMATES.
HELPING THEM IN ASSISTING THEM
IN AND JOBS BETTER SUITED FOR
THE SKILLS THEY HAVE OR SKILLS
THAT WILL HELP THEM WHEN THEY
ARE RELEASED.
WHILE WE HAVE A ROBUST PROGRAM
TO HELP AT THE TAIL END OF
INCARCERATION AND HELPING THEM
TO TRANSITION. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THIS PROCESS IS INTERWOVEN
THROUGH THEIR ENTIRE
INCARCERATION.
COUNSELORS KNOW THEIR INMATES
PASSED
THEY WORK WITH HIM EVERYDAY
UNFORTUNATELY THEY DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO SPEND WITH THEM
INDIVIDUALLY TO HELP GUIDE THEM
ON THAT PATH THROUGH THEIR
INCARCERATION.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
THAT BRINGS US TO A I'D MET AT I
WILL ALSO BE HELD OPEN THAT
BRINGS US TO.
.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN EXCUSE ME
TWENTY. ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY
WHICH IS THE MEDICAL GUARDING
AND TRANSPORTATION.
OKAY WITH THE MEDICAL GUARDING
AND TRANSPORTATION PROPOSAL CCR
REQUESTS FIVE POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN FORTY TWO POINT SEVEN
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER POSITIONS
ON GOING STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
TO AUGMENT OUR THIRD WATCH MADE
GUARDIAN TRANSPORTATION STAFFING.
THESE RESOURCES ARE BASED ON AN
ASSESSMENT THAT THE DEPARTMENT
JUST CONDUCTED OVER.
.
SEVERAL MONTHS FROM MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THROUGH
FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN.
THEY NEED IDENTIFIED THROUGH
THIS ASSESSMENT SUPPORTS THIRTY
FIVE FIVE DAY POSTS.
WHEN APPLYING THE REALLY FACTOR
TO THAT THIRTY FIVE NUMBER YOU
THEN GET TO THE FORTY TWO POINT
SEVEN THAT YOU SEE IN THE B. C.
P.. I'MJOINED AGAIN BY MISS
BARRETTO FROM OUR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS SHE'S GONNA
TELL YOU ALL BUT MORE ABOUT AND
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU BEAST
BECAUSE THESE POSITIONS WILL.
ASSIST US IN REDUCING THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT UNSCHEDULED
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTS HAVE. ON IN
ME. PROGRAMS.
UP THIRD WATCH TO CLARIFY THOSE
OR SHIPS THAT TYPICALLY OCCUR AT
TWO PM TO TEN PM AT NIGHT SO
WELL AFTER OUR MEDICAL PERSONNEL
HAVE PERFORMED THEIR. NORMAL
DUTIES AND A REGULAR HEALTH CARE
APPOINTMENTS
UNSCHEDULED MEDICAL TRANSPORTS
ARE MORE OF AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION WHERE THERE IS
TREATMENT SERVICES REQUIRED IN
THE COMMUNITY. NORMALLY AN
EMERGENCY ROOM.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS EXPERIENCED A
STEADY AND CONTINUOUS INCREASE
AN UNSCHEDULED MEDICAL
TRANSPORTS AND THE LAST TWO
FISCAL YEARS TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN TO TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN. THE
DEPARTMENTS EXPERIENCED A FORTY
SEVEN PERCENT INCREASE ON
UNSCHEDULED EMERGENCY TRANSPORTS.
NGUYEN UNSCHEDULED TRANSPORTS
OCCUR ON THIRD WATCH.
WE HAVE TWO OPTIONS ONE IS TO
HIRE OVERTIME OR THE OTHER WHEN
IT OCCURS MID SHIFT AND STAFF
FROM THE PRIOR SHIFTER NO LONGER
AVAILABLE. IT RESULTS IN US
REDIRECTING EXISTING PASSED THE
STAFF FROM THEIR CURRENT
FUNCTION OUT TO DO THE TRANSPORT.
WHEN THAT OCCURS IT OFTEN
RESULTS IN IN MAY PROGRAM
DISRUPTIONS.
MODIFICATIONS ARE CLOSURES DUE
TO THE REDUCED NUMBER OF
AVAILABLE BECAUSE SEE STAFF.
THIS HAS NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES
ON THE INMATE POPULATION IN
THEIR ABILITY TURN CREDITS AND
ENHANCEMENTS AND REHABILITATIVE
ACHIEVEMENT CREDITS. AND ALSO
BASIC RECREATION LIKE YARD INTO
A ROOM.
THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES AN
IMMEDIATE AND NATIONAL SOLUTION.
IT PROVIDES FOR CONSISTENT
DEDICATED RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
THIS REGULAR ONGOING NEED. BASED
ON THE TRENDS OF UNSCHEDULED
THIRD WATCH MEDICAL TRANSPORTS.
THESE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WELL
EIGHT OUR ABILITY TO REDUCE THE
IMPACT ON IN ME PROGRAMS AS A
RESULT OF THE AND SCHEDULE
TRANSPORTS.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE THE
LAYOFF.
WE DON'T RAISE ANY CONCERNS ON
THIS PROPOSAL WE JUST NOTE THAT
THAT DEPARTMENT IS CONDUCTING A
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION OF
MEDICAL GUARDING AND
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED TO PROVIDE
IT WITH THE RESULTS OF THAT
EVALUATION WHEN THEY'RE
AVAILABLE SO THAT. IT MAY ASSESS REMEMBER CONVERSATION QUESTION.
THANK YOU THAT I WILL ALSO BE
HELD OPEN WE AT ISSUE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE. WHICH IS A HEALTH
CARE SERVICES FOR RE ENTRY.
OKAY.
ON THE HEELS OF A DECISION BY
THE FEDERAL CENTERS FOR MEDICARE
MEDICAID SERVICES THAT CDC OURS
DID NOT QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL
BENEFITS.
THE DEPARTMENT IN AN EFFORT TO
MAINTAIN A LEVEL OF SERVICE
CONSISTENT WITH THAT THAT THE
OFFENDER COULD EXPECT IF THEY
WERE IN ONE OF OUR INSTITUTIONS.
REQUEST TEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
CONTRACT WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES OR.
THIRD PARTY VENDORS TO PROVIDE
HEALTHCARE SERVICES FOR THOSE
OFFENDERS HOUSE IN OUR REENTRY
FACILITIES.
WE BELIEVE THE APPROACH
PROPOSED IN THE BCP ALLOWS FOR A
PREDICTABLE COST STRUCTURE.
RATHER THAN THE UNCERTAINTY
THAT ACCOMPANIES A FEE FOR
SERVICE TYPE ARRANGEMENT.
.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT PROVIDES
A CONSISTENT CONTINUUM OF CARE
FOR OUR PARTICIPANTS WHICH WE
THINK IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
AYE WE BELIEVE RECEIVING A
CONSISTENT LEVEL OF SERVICE FROM
A FAMILIAR PROVIDER ORGANIZATION
INCREASES THE CHANCES OF SUCCESS
FOR OFFENDERS ONCE THEY'RE
RELEASED.
CDC ARE CURRENTLY HAS CAPACITY
WITHIN OUR REENTRY FACILITIES OF
ABOUT A THOUSAND.
THAT INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY.
WITHIN ARE FEMALE C. C. T. R.
P. PROGRAM.
CUSTODY COMMUNITY TRANSITIONAL
REENTRY PROGRAM AND SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BEDS WITHIN OUR.
MALE COMMUNITY REENTRY PROGRAM
WITHIN OUR DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
I'M SPEAKING OF WHICH I AM JOINT
FOR THIS ISSUE BY.
KAREN CRETAN FROM HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
AMY MILLER FROM OUR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSIGHT OF THE
CCT R. P. FEMALE PROGRAM AND
RYAN SOUSA WHO IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITHIN OUR DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
DRP IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OVERSIGHT OF OUR MAIL COMMUNITY
REENTRY PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE
GOING TO PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL ON THE PROPOSAL AND THEY
WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE OVERVIEW OF
WHAT LED US BACK TO. WHERE WE
ARE TODAY WE COULDN'T MORNING
ALMOST GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
TRAINING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES I JUST WANTED TO?
REITERATE THE IMPACT OF. WHAT
LED US HERE AND?
S. ID DIRECTOR LOPEZ SAID
THERE'S MORE THAN A THOUSAND
PATIENTS THAT HAVE BEEN THAT
HAVE FOUND THEMSELVES WITHOUT
COVERAGE OR CARE. ALMOST
OVERNIGHT SO I THINK THAT'S THE
IMMEDIACY OF THIS.
OF THIS PROPOSAL.
AND JUST TO REITERATE LITERATURE
LOPEZ SAID THE PROPOSAL WILL
PROVIDE FOR CONTINUITY OF CARE
COVERAGE AS WELL AS
PREDICTABILITY OF COST FOR THE
DEPARTMENT.
AMY MILLER ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
FOR FEMALE OFFENDER PROGRAM SO I
OVERSEE THE C. C. TRP PROGRAMS
AS OUR FEMALE REENTRY BETS.
OBVIOUSLY THESE RANCHER
PROGRAMS ARE REALLY CRITICAL TO
THE WOMEN.
GOING BACK OUT INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES THEY OFFER A
EXTENSIVE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS THEY OFFER ADDITIONAL
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES
INCLUDING THE ABILITY TO GO TO
COLLEGE AT THE COLLEGES NEARBY.
AND THEY ALSO OFFER AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE WOMEN TO
ACTUALLY GO AND GET A JOB AND BE
GAINFULLY EMPLOYED BUILT THEIR
JOB SKILLS SAVE MONEY. BE ABLE
TO HAVE THAT MONEY AVAILABLE AS
THEY RELEASE IN ORDER TO GO
AHEAD AND SET UP THEIR LIVES AND
GET STARTED AGAIN.
WITH.
THE ALTERNATIVE BECAUSE THE
PROGRAMS WHICH IS PART OF WHAT
THESE ARE WE ARE AS AN AGENCY
FOR I CC ARE MANDATED TO PROVIDE
FOR THAT HEALTH CARE FOR THE
POPULATION THAT IS OUT THERE.
THAT'S PART OF THE PENAL CODE
SECTION EYES SO. I WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR MEDICAL MENTAL
HEALTH AND DENTAL NEEDS EVEN FOR
THOSE MEN AND WOMEN THAT WE HAVE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES. IN ADDITION.
THE PENAL CODE GOES ON TO STATE
THAT EXISTING PSYCHIATRIC OR
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THAT REQUIRE
ONGOING CARE IS NOT A BASIS FOR
EXCLUDING. THOSE PROTESTS BENSON
A MATTER WHAT WE HAVE THOSE MEN
AND WOMEN THEY'RE GOING OUT
THERE TO THOSE PROGRAMS. TO THE
RE ENTRIES AND.
SO HAVING THIS SET MEDICAL
PROGRAM IN PLACE IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO ENSURING THAT
CONTINUITY OF CARE.
THANK YOU. BECOMING SOME FINANCE.
RICHMOND DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
JUST WANNA KNOW THAT WHAT WE'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW IS MERELY A STOP
GAP TO PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
THOSE FOLKS WHO WERE MEDI CAL
ELIGIBLE NO LONGER ARE. WHO ARE
IN A REENTRY PROGRAMS WE DON'T
SEE IT AS A SINGLE SOLUTION
MOVING FORWARD?
THIS PROPOSAL THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT
TO CONTRACT WITH PROVIDERS
THROUGH DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. YOU THE PROVIDERS IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT THE PROVIDING
A LEVEL OF SERVICE COMPATIBLE TO
WHAT INMATES HAD WHEN THEY WERE
IN PRISON. AND THERE'S ALSO A
POSSIBILITY THAT INMATES WILL BE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE SAME
PROVIDERS UPON RELEASE.
AND.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JONATHAN PETERSON AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE REJECT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES IN
THESE REENTRY FACILITIES ON A
CONTRACT BASIS. AND INSTEAD
DIRECT THE CDC ARE TO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AT REENTRY FACILITIES ON AN AS
NEEDED BASIS AS THEY'VE BEEN
DOING SINCE THE DECISION FROM.
THE CENTER FOR A MEDICARE
SERVICES CAME DOWN AND.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THIS WOULD
ALLOW MORE DETAILED PROPOSAL TO
BE DEVELOPED FOR AYE JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT MORE TIME TO CLARIFY
HOW MUCH IT WOULD COST TO
PROVIDE SERVICES THROUGH THIS
CONTRACTED MODEL.
VERSES ON A FEE FOR SERVICE
MODEL IN THAT WHICH THEY'VE BEEN
USING FOR A COUPLE MONTHS A
SENSE THE DECISION. AND THAT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW AN OPPORTUNITY
TO GET TO INVESTIGATE WHETHER
THERE ARE ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS TO
PROVIDING THIS CARE IN THESE
FACILITIES.
OKAY.
ANY OMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE.
MEMBERS.
OKAY FINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BRINGS US TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
TWO.
CASE RECORD TRAINING TING
.
OKAY WITH OUR CASE RECORDS
TRAINING TEAM PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
AND THREE CASE RECORDS
ADMINISTRATOR POSITIONS.
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THE STAFF WOULD BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR PROVIDING TRAINING TO ALL
CASE RECORD STAFF BOTH AT THE
INSTITUTIONS AND HEADQUARTERS ON
CALCULATING OFFENDER SENTENCES
AND RELEASE STATES. I'M JOINED
AGAIN BY MISS BARRETTO FROM OUR
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS
WHO'S GONNA TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE PROPOSAL THAT
WE BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON.
CASE RECORD STAFF ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR DETERMINING
INMATES CREDIT EARNING RATE USED
TO CALCULATE AN INMATE'S REALLY
STATE.
SUCH CALCULATIONS WERE BASED ON
A VAST ARRAY OF SENTENCING LAWS
AND REGULATIONS.
CASE RECORD STAFF MUST ENSURE
ACCURATE INTERPRETATION AND
CALCULATION OF AN INMATE'S
RELEASE DATE OR BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARING DATE.
EXCEEDINGLY COMPLICATED
SENTENCING CALCULATION
METHODOLOGIES.
ARE BECOMING MORE AND MORE
FREQUENT. AS A RESULT OF ONGOING
FREQUENT CHANGES DUE TO NEW CASE
LAW COURT RULES PROGRAMS AND
LEGISLATIVE MANDATES.
IT'S IMPERATIVE FOR CASE RECORD
STAFF TO HAVE THE PROPER
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
ALL STATUTES REGULATIONS
POLICIES BOTH PAST AND CURRENT.
TO ENSURE AN INMATE'S SENTENCES
RECORDED ACCURATELY THROUGHOUT
INCARCERATION.
SAP MUST BE TRAINED
APPROPRIATELY TO ENSURE RELEASE
STATES HAVE BEEN COMPUTED
PURSUANT TO EACH LAW.
AND TO THE SPECIFICS OF AN
INMATE'S TERM.
USING A REGIONAL APPROACH THESE
THREE POSITIONS PROVIDE TRAINING
TO CASE RECORDS OFFICES IN THE
REGION. ALLOWING FOR BOTH
CLASSROOM ENSURE SIDE HANDS ON
TRAINING TO ALL STAFF.
AN URGENT CHANGING LAWS MANDATES
ARE PROGRAMS AS THEY OCCUR WHICH
THEY FREQUENTLY DO. THESE STAFF
WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE
THE NECESSARY ON THE SPOT
INFORMATION AND TRAINING TO THE
INSTITUTION CASE RECORD STAFF
IMMEDIATELY.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. ANY COMMENTS OR FINANCE
BELIAU.
NICK MEMBERS QUESTIONS
IT COMES FROM THE AUDIENCE.
IF THANK YOU THAT I THEM WILL
HELP BE HELD OPEN OR NOT I'D
WITH THEM OF TWENTY THREE. WHICH
IS PSYCHIATRIC OF REGISTRY
FUNDING.
GOOD MORNING AT ONCE AGAIN.
DOING READER WITH KATHARINE
DREXEL HEALTHCARE SERVICES.
WE'VE A PROPOSAL FOR EIGHTEEN
POINT ONE MILLION OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS.
TO FILL FUNDING GAP.
CREATED BY IN INCREASE IN
REGISTRY COSTS FOR PSYCHIATRIC.
PROVIDERS.
THE DEPARTMENT WENT OUT FOR BID.
AND.
PROCURED A CONTRACT.
THERE'S THERE'S A A GLUT IN
PSYCHIATRY PROVIDERS.
NATIONWIDE AND THE COSTS TO GET
THOSE REGISTRY PROVIDERS AND HAS
INCREASED.
WHILE OUR MID STEP FUNDING HAS
REMAINED THE SAME.
SO WE WERE ARE REQUESTING A TO
YOUR AUGMENTATION.
.
TO GET THROUGH THE NEXT TWO
FISCAL YEARS.
IN ORDER TO DO SOME ADDITIONAL
VALUATION AND GET TO A NINETY
PERCENT FILL RATE.
WE WERE.
COURT ORDERED BY THE FEDERAL
COURTS. TO HAVE A NINETY PERCENT
FILL RATE.
FOR PROVIDERS.
BY OCTOBER OF EIGHTEEN SO THIS
FUNDING IS CRITICAL IN ORDER FOR
US TO GET TO THAT LEVEL.
OF STAFFING.
MOVING AHEAD AND WHY WE'VE ASKED
FOR TO YOUR AUGMENTATION IS
WE'RE LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT
AVENUES.
TO FILL THAT NEED.
POSSIBLY EXPANSION OF
TELEMEDICINE WHICH HAS PROVEN
SUCCESSFUL.
POSSIBLE ADDITIONAL COMPLEMENT
COMPENSATION TO DO IT.
PAY INCREASES THAT ARE MORE
COMPARABLE TO.
THE FREE WORLD. AND THEN ALSO
DOING SOME EVALUATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH STAFF IN.
FOR THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
THE VEIL OF TO TAKE QUESTIONS AS
NAY COMING SO FINANCER OLEO.
OKAY ANY AUDIENCE COMMENTS
MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU THAT I WANT TO BE
HELD THANK YOU NOW AT ITEM YOU
SHOULD TWENTY FOUR WHICH IS
SUPPORT RECENT THINGS.
PETITIONS
.
OKAY AT WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION ON GOING STARTING.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO FULLY UTILIZE PENAL CODE
ELEVEN SEVENTY D.. WHICH ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT TO REQUEST OF THE
RECALL AND RE SENTENCING OF
INMATES WHO HAVE EXHIBITED
EXCEPTIONAL CONDUCT OR WHOSE
RECORDS CONTAIN SENTENCING
ERRORS.
THIS PROPOSAL REQUESTS THIRTEEN
POSITIONS INCLUDING FIVE CASE
RECORD STAFF THREE COUNSELORS.
FIVE ADMINISTER AND FIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND SUPPORT STAFF
THE FUNDING ALSO REQUEST
RESOURCES FOR TWO TWO YEAR
LIMITED TERM POSITIONS. WITHIN
OUR A DIVISION OF ADULT
INSTITUTIONS AND MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE CASE RECORDS
MANAGEMENT AND CLASSIFICATION
SERVICES UNIT WITHIN THAT
DIVISION.
I'M HERE ALONE AND EXPECTED
LEAVE BUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT
HAVE.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
LA JOH ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
ANY QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
OKAY LIMIT MOVES US TO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE.
YOU GOT OFF EASY TIME WITHOUT I.
ALL EXCEL WHEN I GET OUT THE
DOOR THANK YOU.
THIS BRINGS US THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
AND THE CYBER ITEM TWENTY FIVE
IS CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM
RESOURCE PROPOSAL.
MONEY MANAGER CHRIS RYAN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I THIS REQUEST IS THERE SO
CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM EYES TO
PROVIDE THAT.
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO THE
CYBERSECURITY PROGRAM TO ENSURE
THE INFORMATION SECURITY LAW
ENFORCEMENT NETWORKS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA ARE SECURED.
AND I HAVE TIED UP ITS IN HERE
FROM THE.
SEE JUST.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
YEAH.
YEAH ANSWER QUESTIONS OR MAKE A
STATEMENT.
ARE BEING ALL EVERYWHERE YOU
WANT MAN OKAY THEM SEE IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS FIRST
ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE ILIO.
ANY KIND ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE MEMBERS.
WELL THIS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DRIVING I DON'T HAVE THE HELD
OPEN.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX WHICH IS
CYBER CRIME INVESTIGATION TEAM.
CHRIS RYAN DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
IN THIS IS TO ESTABLISH TO
INVESTIGATIVE TEAMS ONE IN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION AND
ONE IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION FOCUSING ON CYBER CRIMES
WHITE COLLAR CRIMES OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CRIMES. INVOLVING
THE USE OF TECHNOLOGY EACH OF
THE TWO TEAMS WILL HANDLE
APPROXIMATE THIRT CASES PER
YEAR. HANDED REQUESTS FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
FOUR POINT EIGHT MILLION GENERAL
FUND IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONGOING.
JOHN MARSHALL HERE FROM OUR
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS
FIND ANY COMMENTS FROM FINANCE
ILLEGAL. OKAY UNEASILY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BELIEVES THAT THIS
IS A PRIORITY WE DO RECOMMEND
PROVIDING THE RESOURCES ON A
THREE YEAR LIMITED TERM BASIS.
AND THE REASON WHY WE'RE MAKING
THIS RECOMMENDATION IS THIS
RESPONSIBILITY IS NEW. FOR DOJ
AND SAID THERE IS UNCERTAINTY
AND THE NUMBER OF CASES THAT
WOULD BE INVESTIGATED AND
PROSECUTED HOW LONG THEY COULD
TAKE WHAT TYPES OF RESOURCES
WOULD POTENTIALLY BE NEEDED ON
AN ONGOING BASIS AND WHAT THE
IMPACT WOULD BE. FOR THE STATE
SO IN LINE WITH THAT WE ALSO DO
RECOMMEND REQUIRING DOJ SUBMIT A
REPORT.
BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ON VARIOUS OUTCOME MEASURES
SUCH AS THE ONES THAT WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT.
NUMBER OF CASES AND THE
OUTCOMES OF THOSE CASES TO THAT
PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
INFORMATION DETERMINE WHAT LEVEL
OF ONGOING RESOURCES IS NEEDED
GOING FORWARD.
OKAY.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE.
AUDIENCE MEMBERS.
OKAY THANK YOU I DON'T WANT TO
COMMENT ON THAT YEAH WE'RE COMIN.
JUST A PROGRAM IN GENERAL THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS PROGRAM IS
IDENTIFIED A GAP WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OTHER SOME
GOOD WORK BEING DONE BY THE
FEDERAL AGENCIES AND SOME SOME
LOWER LEVEL WORK BEING DONE BY
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THERE'S
THIS HUGE GAP IN THE MIDDLE.
SPY AS FAR CYBER CRIME.
WORK.
I WAS AT A NATIONAL CONFERENCE
AND AND.
WORKING WITH OTHER STATES AND
OTHER STATES ARE FAR AHEAD OF US
AS FAR AS OUR WORK IN THE CYBER
AREA WHICH IS. ALMOST SOMEWHAT
EMBARRASSING BECAUSE WE ARE THE
TECH COMPANY.
OR TEXT STATE OF THE OF THE
NATION.
SO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IDENTIFIED THIS HUGE GAP IN.
JUST SOME OF THE AREAS LIKE THE
DREAM MARKET OF JUST SOME TERMS
THAT THAT ARE OUT THERE THE.
TOWER SERVER THE ONION AND
THESE ARE ALL. AREAS THAT.
PEOPLE ARE WORKING ILLEGALLY
AND AND THE DREAM MARKET IS KIND
OF DESCRIBE THIS THAT EBAY. OF
FOR CRIMINALS YOU CAN BUY
ANYTHING THAT YOU WANT ON THE
STARK WEB ANYTHING THAT'S
ILLEGAL THAT YOU CAN'T BUY LEGAL
YOU CAN GET THERE FROM DRUGS TO.
PEOPLE TO ANY TYPE OF THE LEGAL
SERVICES IN A MURDER FOR HIRE
AND WERE NOT WORKING IN THAT
AREA AND NOBODY IN A STATEWIDE
EFFORT IS WORKING IN THAT AREA.
AND IT'S A IT'S A HUGE GAP IN IT
SO THAT IT'S AN AREA OF CONCERN.
AND SO POSSESS SOME TERMS BUT I
WANTED TO JUST TOUCH ON ON
LIMITED TERM FUNDING AND FOR DOJ.
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
THERE'S BEEN SOME OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT.
HAVE HAD LINEN LIMITED TERM
FUNDING ATTACHED TO IT AND JUST
THE STATE PROCESSFOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO HIRE. RIGHT NOW FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND THE DOJ WE USUALLY HIRE
EXPERIENCED INVESTIGATORS AND
WHEN YOU PUT A LIMITED TERM
FUNDING ATTACHED TO THAT.
I'M TRYING TO GET LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM FROM OTHER
AREAS THAT HAVE EXPERIENCE IN
THIS AREA TO COME WORK FOR DOJ
BUT I CAN ONLY PROMISE THEM
THREE YEAR FUNDING IN AND YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR AN
ESTABLISHED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER THAT HOUSE STABLE.
A STABLE JOB TO SAY HEY I WANT
TO GO DO THAT FOR A THREE YEAR
PERIOD BECAUSE THAT'S ALL I CAN
COMMIT TO THEM. SO IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO TO HIRE THE
THE BEST AND THE BRIGHTEST TO DO
THIS TYPE OF WORK. FOR A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME SO I JUST I I
THOUGHT WE WOULD BE REMISS NOT
TO MENTION THAT AND WHEN YOU
HIRE THESE TYPES OF PEOPLE
THERE'S A LEARNING CURVE TO IT
AND. JUST GIVING IDEA TAKES
ABOUT TWELVE MONTHS THE HIGHER
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER AND THEN
TO GET INTO DO THIS TYPE OF WORK
YOU NEED SPECIALTY TRAINING AND
THAT'S ANOTHER SIX TO TWELVE
MONTHS SO WE'RE TALKING TWO
YEARS BEFORE WE GET. YOU KNOW
ESTABLISHED AND REALLY START
DOING WORK IN THIS AREA SO.
I JUST WANTED TO ADD THAT THANK
YOU.
I KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME PROBLEMS
THAT PASSED WITH LIMITED TERM
EMPLOYMENT.
AND PEOPLE MUSTANG SO OKAY WILL
LOOK INTO THAT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
MEMBERS.
OKAY THAT BRINGS THEM TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BELIEVE THAT ITEM
HOPE THAT BRINGS US TO AYE ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN. WHICH IS
SEX OFFENDER REGISTRY.
CHAPTER FIVE FORTY ONE STATUES
OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
THEN THEY MANAGER CHRIS RYAN
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE AGAIN AND
THIS IS THE.
REQUEST TO IMPLEMENT.
SP THREE OR AS YOU MENTIONED.
THIS TEN MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST
I REPRESENTS THE FIRST YEAR
FUNDING ASSOCIATED WITH THIS
PROJECT AND A TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS. I HAVE LINDA I HEAR
FROM THE PROGRAM TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
.
A COME INTO FINANCE PEMBA CHEN
WORTH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I
JUST WANT TO ADD THAT.
CURRENTLY IN THE. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY EVEN WORKING TOGETHER
ON THE POWER PROCESS FOR. SB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR.
THERE I THINK RIGHT NOW
PROJECTING TO BE DONE AND
COMPLETED WITH POWELL BY JANUARY
AND SO THIS PROPOSAL IS ONLY FOR
ONE YEAR FUNDING THE PLAN WOULD
BE IN THE BCP THAT'S HAVE BEEN A
NEXT YEAR. WILL INCLUDE A PLAN
FOR ONGOING IMPLEMENTATION NOT
ONLY OF OF THE TECHNOLOGY
PORTION BUT ALSO ALSO FOR THE
PROGRAM IN GENERAL.
AND THEN WE WILL CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSIONS ON IMPLEMENTATION
DURING HEARINGS NEXT YEAR IT
FRONT THANK YOU INCUMBENTS
MELLOW.
WE DON'T HAVE PARTICULAR
CONCERNS WITH THE REQUESTED
FUNDING BECAUSE IT IS FOR THE
FIRST YEAR BUT BECAUSE IT IS FOR
THE FIRST YEAR WE HAVE KIND OF
BROADER RECOMMENDATIONS. TO HELP
THE LEGISLATURE MONITOR.
THIS SIDE NEW KIND OF IT
PROJECT INNER AND THE PROJECTED
COST CURRENTLY AS SIXTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR DOLLARS OVER FIVE
YEARS. AND SO WE HAVE REPORTED
RECOMMENDATIONS INTO ASPECTS.
THE FIRST IS WE ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND.
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE THAT
DOJ SUBMIT A REPORT OUTLINING
ITS FULL PLAN FOR FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REGISTRY.
THE STEPS THAT PLANS TO TAKE HOW
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED AND THE FULL AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES FUNDING AND
STAFFING THAT WOULD BE NEEDED.
AT THE COMPLETION OF STAGE TWO
OF THE POWER PROCESS OR THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE
PROCESS.
BEFORE IT KIND OF MOVES INTO THE
PROCUREMENT STAGE OF STAGE THREE
SO THE LEGISLATURE REALLY HAS AN
IDEA OF WHAT THOSE TOTAL COSTS
ARE.
THE SECOND ASPECT IS WE ARE ALSO
RECOMMENDING THAT DOJ.
PROVIDE ANNUAL PROGRESS REPORTS
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON KEY
METRICS
SO FOR EXAMPLE THE TASKS THAT
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED WHETHER
THERE HAVE BEEN ANY COST CHANGES
ARE DELAYS AND PROJECT
MILESTONES. AND IF THERE ARE ANY
CHALLENGES ARE RISKS THAT HAVE
MANIFESTED ITSELF IN WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING TO
ESSENTIALLY OFFSET THAT OR
ADDRESS.
AND SO. THAT WILL REALLY HELP
THE LEGISLATURE ENSURE THAT THE
PROJECT STAYS ON SCHEDULE AND ON
BUDGET.
AND.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE
CATHOLIC PUBLIC COMMITTEE ON
OKAY I HOPE THEM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I'M. SO THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
PROVIDE THE FOUNDATIONAL
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY IN ORDER FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO TRANSITION. FROM
THE CURRENT LIFETIME
REGISTRATION SYSTEM TO A TIER
BASED SYSTEM BY JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THIS REQUIREMENT THIS WILL
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO DO
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES INCLUDING
COLLECTING NEW DATA BOTH AT THE
STATE AND NATIONAL LEVEL.
PROVIDING NEW DATA COLLECTION
METHODS THAT ARE SO.
STANDARDIZE ITS DISTINCT
SUSTAINABLE AND ALSO A NEW
BUSINESS PARTNERS CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BUSINESS PARTNERS WILL
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE US
THAT DATA. BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
IT WILL REQUIRE US TO MAKE MAJOR
ENHANCEMENTS TO OUR TECHNOLOGIES
AND OUR INTERFACES AND THEN.
ACQUIRE NEW STAFF TO COME ON AND
TRAIN STAFF TO DO ALL THE MANUAL
WORK THAT WILL BE REQUIRED TO DO
THIS. IT'S A VERY EXTENSIVE
ALMOST A FIVE YEAR PROJECT AND
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO COMPLETE THE
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFE CYCLE.
WHICH INCLUDES ASKS
PUTTING TOGETHER A DETAILED
PROJECT PLAN AND TWELVE
ADDITIONAL PLANS THAT COVER
EVERYTHING FROM RISK.
CONSTRAINTS ANY ISSUES
COMMUNICATIONS AND WERE ALMOST
WE HAVE COMPLETED STATE ONE.
WHERE ALMOST DONE WITH STAGE TWO
WHAT'S VERY IMPORTANT IS THAT WE
CONDUCT THIS PROJECT AND THE
SYSTEMATIC ORDER WE HAVE TO HAVE
THE MONEY?
TO THAT THIS IS THE FOUNDATION
FOR THE ENTIRE FIVE YEARS OF THE
PROJECT SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE HAVE THE MONEY TO BUILD THE
TECHNOLOGIES.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO GET THOSE
TECHNOLOGIES IN PLACE SO WE CAN
HAVE THE DATA THAT WE NEED IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE THE NEW TEARS.
WE ALL STAFF ALSO HAVE TO HOW
THOSE DATA EXCHANGE METHODS IN
PLACE.
SO WORKERS A CRIMINAL JUSTICE
BUSINESS PARTNERS CAN GIVE US
THAT DATA AND THEN WE HOP HAVE
TO HAVE THAT TECHNOLOGY IN PLACE
SO ALL THOSE FOLKS THAT WE ARE
HIRING TO DO THE MANUAL WORK.
WILL HAVE SOMEWHERE TO PUT THAT
DATA AND THE DATA WILL REMAIN
FRESH AND BE ABLE TO BE
PROCESSED WHEN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
BUSINESS PARTNERS NEED THAT.
SO WE NEED TO MAKE SURE. THAT WE
HAVE THAT DATA ON ON GOING THAT
THE FUNDS ON AN ONGOING BASIS TO
ENSURE THAT THIS. PROJECT THAT
COMES TO FRUITION AND THAT
THROUGH THE POWER PROJECT WHAT.
A PROCESS THAT WE ARE COMPLETING
RIGHT NOW WE'VE COMPLETED STAGE
ONE STAGE TWO ARE ALL THESE
THINGS THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
WANTING IN THESE REPORTS ALL
THESE DIFFERENT PLANS THAT YOU
LAND PLACE. THAT IS DONE IN
STAGE TWO AND STAGE THREE FOR US
NEEDS TO START ON JULY FIRST OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SO WE CAN
HAVE VENDORS ON BOARD AND ON
SITE.
START BUILDING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES ARE WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO MAKE THE MANDATED
REQUIREMENTS TO IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL BY JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
OKAY ONLY ONCE COMMENTS IN THE
AUDIENCE.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT ITEM TWO IS BEING HELD OPEN
WITH ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
AT THIS POINT. STATEWIDE
FORENSIC SERVICES.
A MADAM CHAIR CHRIS RYAN
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THIS
REQUEST IS A.
PROPOSAL TO SUPPORT OUR FRIENDS
EX SERVICES IT'S ELEVEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. AYE IT'S
MADE UP OF TWO COMPONENTS THE
FIRST ONE IS A SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ASSOCIATE WITH THE
REVENUE THAT HAS BEEN DECLINING
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS. AND
THEN FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION
ASSOCIATED WITH EQUIPMENT
REFRESH ASSOCIATED WITH LAB
EQUIPMENT.
AND VERY MILLER IS HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE BELIAU.
WE GENERALLY DON'T HAVE CONCERNS
WITH THE OVERALL PACKAGE ON THE
WE WOULD MENTION THAT RELATED TO
THE FIVE POINT FOUR MILLION TO
REPLACE FORENSIC ACQUIT MEANT.
HE WOULD ONLY REPLACE A SMALL
SUBSET OF THE EQUIPMENT AND SO
WE DO RECOMMEND ON THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED DOJ TERRACE
SUBMIT A REPORT BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN ON IT'S LARGER
PLAN RELATED TO FRIENDS
EQUIPMENT IN THIS PLAN SHOULD
INCLUDE ESSENTIALLY IN INVENTORY
OF WHAT EQUIPMENT IS THERE WHAT
EQUIPMENT THEY THINK IS NEEDED.
HOW LONG EACH OF THOSE THE EACH
OF THE MACHINES OR EQUIPMENT
COULD OPERATE AND WHAT THE PLAN
IS IN TERMS OF COSTS ON AN
ONGOING BASIS? IN THIS
INFORMATION WILL HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DECIDE YOU KNOW WHAT
ACTION IF ANY TO KIND OF TAKE IN
THE FUTURE.
OKAY. ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
HERE. ALRIGHT THANK YOU LEAVE
THAT ITEM OPEN AYE LAST ITEM IS
YOU SEEN ON THE TWENTY NINTH.
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS.
SO I WILL ACTUALLY BE PRESENTING
US ON ON BEHALF OF
ADMINISTRATION. SO THE MAYOR
VISION PROPOSES TO SHIFT
BEGINNING IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THE BUDGET ACT APPROPRIATIONS
FOR NON MEDICAL PROP FIFTY SIX.
FUNDS TO CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS. THE SHIFT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEGAL
INTERPRETATION OF EXISTING LAW
WHICH REQUIRES THAT REVENUES BE
CONTINUES THE APPROPRIATED FOR
PURPOSES AND FURTHERANCE OF THE
PROPOSITION.
IN ADDITION TO THAT YOU FUNDS
CREATED BY THE INITIATIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS
ADMINISTRATIVE WE ESTABLISHED
FUNDS TO AID DEPARTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS AND TRACKING THEIR PROP
FIFTY SIX ALLOCATIONS AND
EXPENDITURES. AND TO PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY. THE ADMINISTRATION
FURTHER PROPOSES THE CHANGE TO
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS TO
PROVIDE GREATER FLEXIBILITY IN
SPENDING PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDS.
THIS CHANGE AFFECTS PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX EXPENDITURES FOR
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THESE
APARTMENTS RECEIVED PROP
SIXTEENTH IS FIFTY SIX FUNDING.
THROUGH BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATIONS DURING.
THE FIRST YEAR OF THE
PROPOSITION IMPLEMENTATION OF
OFFICE CLEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
THESE FUNDS WITH CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION ITEMS WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE FUN CONDITION
STATEMENTS.
DISPLAY AS PART OF THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS OF THE LOW.
THE DEPARTMENT THE LEGISLATURE
SEQUEL BUSH CAN CAN MONITOR THE
BALANCE IN THE FUNDS.
REFLECTS IT.
ANY COMMENTS FROM LA UP.
WE ARE UMBRAGE RECOMMENDING
REJECTING ALL OF THE REQUESTS
RELATED AND TO THIS CHANGE.
AND SO A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT
AT THIS IMPACTS MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS THE ONLY AREA THAT I
THINK TO OUR KNOWLEDGE.
WHERE THIS WASN'T REQUESTED FOR
IS RELATED TO MEDI CAL?
AND SO I'M WE DO AGREE THAT THE
LANGUAGE OF THE INITIATIVE TALKS
ABOUT CONTINUES APPROPRIATION
FOR THE FIND. HOWEVER WE WOULD
NOTE THAT SOME OF THE
ALLEGATIONS AS REQUIRED BY THE
PROPOSITION.
INVOLVED CHOICES THAT ARE KIND
OF FUNDAMENTALLY INCOMPATIBLE
WITH THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS ARE TO GIVE YOU
AN EXAMPLE.
THE REVENUE AND TAXATION CODE
ACTUALLY SPECIFIES THAT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND
FEE ADMINISTRATION RECEIVE NOT
MORE THAN FIVE PERCENT OF NET
REVENUE. AND SO LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET PROCESS THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED ON THE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY APPROVED AN
AMOUNT THAT WAS LESS THAN THAT
FIVE PERCENT. IS WITH THE
CONTINUES APPROPRIATION IT'S
ACTUALLY UNCLEAR TO US HOW THAT
AMOUNT WOULD BE DETERMINED AND
HOW WE WOULD NOW.
AND SO GIVEN ADEQUATE TIME AND
CONSIDERATION THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT DECIDE THAT A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION IN CERTAIN AREAS
SUCH AS FOR DOJ IS APPROPRIATE.
BUT BECAUSE THERE'S WE DON'T SEE
AN NEED.
TO KIND OF RUSSIAN MAKE A
DECISION AT THIS TIME WE
ACTUALLY THINK THIS DECISION CAN
BE MADE IN JANUARY NEXT YEAR.
ANY COMMENTS ON THE.
OKAY ANY AUDIO MADAM CHAIR JUST
ONE COMMENT RELATIVE TO THE
DEPARTMENT JUST AS WE HAVE AT A
LOCAL GRANTS TO GO OUT AND SO
THERE'S A POT OF MONEY SPECIFIED
IN THE.
IN THE PROPOSITION THIRTY
MILLION ON ANNUALLY.
AT THE WOULD BE. ALLOW US A
LITTLE MORE FLEXIBILITY THROUGH
A CONTINUOUS PREPARATION.
RATHER THAN WAITING FOR AN
AMOUNT TO BE APPROPRIATED OR TO
GO THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS GIVEN THAT IT IS
SPECIFIED.
IN THE.
IN THE PROP FIFTY SIX LANGUAGE
SO WE WOULD SUPPORT THE
ACADEMIA'S PREPARATION.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS MEMBERS.
AUDIENCE OF CONFINEMENT THAT
ITEM TO WILL BE HELD OPEN THAT
CONCLUDES OUR MEETING FOR TODAY
THE MEETING IS ADJOURNED. AND WE
WILL BE MEETING AGAIN I GUESS ON
MONDAY.
TO TAKE ACTION ON A NUMBER OF
ITEMS.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
MEETING IS ADJOURNED